foreign
and welcome back to Simply learns
YouTube channel in this comprehensive
ethical hacking crash course we'll dive
deep into the realm of ethical hacking
where we'll learn the art of securing
digital Landscapes while keeping the
digital world safe from malicious intent
so whether you are a beginner or an
experienced Tech Enthusiast this course
will equip you with the skills and
knowledge needed to become a proficient
ethical hacker but before we begin if
you enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn
if you are interested in pursuing a
career in cyber security and acquiring
the necessary skills then a postgraduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with the MIT University is
surely the right option for you gain
expertise in defensive and offensive
cyber security digital forensics ethical
hacking penetration testing and other
crucial domains with this intensive
program a comprehensive program offers a
curriculum encompassing various
in-demand cyber security tools Hands-On
labs and guided practices
pincher your Readiness for the industry
you will also engage in multiple
projects allowing you to hone your
skills and emerge as an exceptional
cyber security professional furthermore
this course will help you learn the
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance the Learners may have a
non-programming background and one plus
year of experience is preferred for this
program so hurry up and find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below for more details so let's take a
minute to hear it out from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers finishing the course led
to personal recognition and open the
door for even more artificial
intelligence projects and it came with
significant pay raise my hand hi I'm
Philip I'm 61 years old in last year's
compiled skill was simple as
post-granting program inside of security
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course we decided to
make a course in devops from Simply
learning the course is very beneficial
for both our careers yeah I got a
promotion after the course and I go to
hire with a new company at first I'd
like to learn from video and then apply
for your job foreign
because of its tremendously High waiting
to be rated as one of the best Education
portal online worldwide is truly
promising I switched to a new world as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confidence boost alongside numerous
other possible outcomes
this video will cover everything you
need to know about ethical ethical
hacking we'll cover topics like what is
ethical hacking followed by the types of
ethical hackers not only that but will
also cover the skills required to become
an ethical hacker and then we'll cover
topics like what is Kali Linux and how
it is used for ethical hacking we'll
also cover the best programming
languages for ethical hacking and will
take you through a Hands-On demo of how
python is used for ethical hacking
covering topics like SQL injection is
necessary if we talk about ethical
hacking we'll end this video with a
detailed roadmap of how to become an
ethical hacker in 2023 so grab your pen
and paper and buckle yourself up to
explore the field of ethical hacking so
without any further delay let's get
started with what is ethical hacking
data is the new goal imagine how much
data is generated by just your
smartphone every single day read the
pictures you click or the messages you
send nearly 41 million messages are sent
worldwide via WhatsApp every single
minute so safeguarding your personal
data against hackers has now become a
top priority
did you know that India leads the world
when it comes to ethical hackers with 23
of the worldwide hacking population from
India
the top ethical hackers earn more than
twice of what software engineers in
India do but what makes ethical hacking
such a demanding industry ethical
hacking is the process of taking
security measures to safeguard data and
networks from malicious cyber attacks
the hackers use every tool at their
disposal to try and breach the security
barrier and find any potential
vulnerabilities the ethical and ethical
hacking denotes the lack of malicious
intent since these sessions are often
permitted by the system owner or the
network that is being hacked into to fix
any compromised entry points before
black hat hackers discover and exploit
them so what is a black hat hacker you
may ask a hacker who exploits security
vulnerabilities from monetary gains like
stealing or destroying private data
altering disrupting or shutting down
websites and networks is known as a
black hat hacker
on the other end of the spectrum we have
white hat hackers who help people secure
the networks by stress testing their
platform against the most dangerous of
cyber attacks that is with their consent
of course but the most neutral of the
bunch are gray hat hackers who may not
ask for consent before snooping on a
foreign system but they do inform the
owner if they find any vulnerabilities
sometimes in exchange for a small fee
the security breaches have become less
and less prevalent thanks to rigorous
ethical hacking campaigns and corporate
awareness programs the ability to fix
critical security issues before blackout
hackers leverage them has saved
organizations billions of dollars Google
IBM Microsoft and virtually every major
corporation are looking to protect the
data so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that ethical hacking and information
security job market is set to rise by
nearly 28 by 2026 but salary is going as
high as 225 000 per annum let's
understand what are the types of hackers
so what are the types of hackers hacker
is a technically skilled person who is
very Adept with computers they have good
programming skills they understand how
operating system works they understand
how networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers white
hat hackers gray hat script kitties
Nation spell sponsored hackers and a
hack twist so blackout hackers are very
basically uh the malicious hackers who
have malicious intent and have
criminalistic Tendencies they want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying their data
so that they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective these guys are also
known as crackers the main aspect of
these people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity uh they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white ad hacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who's an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security posture so
these uh these kind of Security Experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks gray hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kiddies are people uh who are
technically not much aware about what
hacking is they rely on existing tools
that that have been created by other
hackers they have no technical knowledge
of what they're doing it's just a hit or
miss for them so they just get their
hands on a tool they try to execute
those tools if the hack works it works
otherwise it doesn't so these people are
basically who are noobs or newbies who
are trying to learn hacking or uh just
uh people who with malicious intent who
just want to have some fun or trying to
impress people around then we have the
nation or the state sponsored hackers as
the name suggests these hackers are
sponsored by their government now this
may not be a legitimate job but most of
the governments do have hackers enrolled
in their pay on on their organizations
to spy on their enemies to spy on
various countries and try to figure out
uh the aspirations of those countries so
this is basically a spying activity
where you are technically trying to get
access to other countries resources and
then try to spy on them to figure out
what their activities have been or what
their future plans have been and then we
have the hacktivists who is an
individual who has a political agenda to
promote and they promote it by doing
hacking so these guys what is the
difference between a black hat hacker
and a hacktivist the black hat hacker
may try to hide their identity a
hacktivist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda a political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking then we have discussed the types
of hackers we have identified a
malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what they
are allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and the ethical hackers
would function within those Scopes would
try to execute those at test scenarios
where they would be able to identify
those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhead hackers do however
the main difference here is that these
guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand how various
components in a computer work they can
troubleshoot those components and they
can basically be very good with
programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so here you can see the
ethical hacker there are individuals who
perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they've been configured and
if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a ethical hacker
they would give the ethical hacker the
information about what information is or
what security controls what firewalls
the what idss ipss intrusion detection
or intrusion prevention systems
anti-viruses already in place and then
they will ask the ethical hacker to
figure out a way to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization what is the need
of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive of security
the ethical hacker would identify all
the existing flaws in an organization
and try to resolve those laws to help
secure the organization from black hat
hackers so ethical hackers would prevent
Hackers from cracking into an
organization's Network by securing the
organization by improving on their
security on a periodic basis and they
would also try to identify system
vulnerabilities Network vulnerabilities
or application Level vulnerabilities
that would have been missed or have
already been missed and then tried to
figure out a way of plugging them or
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization's
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity T
for example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are they contain the alphabet A through
Z uppercase and low case 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and they
are randomized so that the password
becomes much more stronger to prevent
from Brute Force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if Brute Force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they would ensure that
all the employees are following the
policies and all the passwords are as
secured as the policies want them to be
if there are any gaps in the policies or
the implementation of the policy it is
the ethical Hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and want the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they will try to protect it by from
falling into the Hacker's hands now what
what are the skills that are required of
an ethical hacker these are the
following skills so first and foremost
they should have good knowledge with
operating systems such as Windows Linux
Unix and Mac now when we say knowledge
about operating systems it's not only
about how to use those operating systems
but how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security Center of Windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with Linux and Mac
softwares operating systems so we need
to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as an
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time there should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
PHP python Ruby HTML for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for and ethical
hackers should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're an application security
you're in network security or you're in
host based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a land
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the OSI model we should
should know which protocols work on
those seven layers we should identify
the TCP model and how OSI model can be
mapped to the TCP model we should
understand how TCP and UDP work how how
each and every protocol is crafted how
they are supposed to behave for us to
analyze and understand any network based
attacks we should be very good in
security measures so we should know
where those vulnerabilities would lie
what are the latest exploits available
in the market and we should be able to
identify them we should be able to know
the techniques and the tools of how to
deal with security how to analyze
security and then how to implement
security to enhance it as well along
with that it is important that a
security analyst or ethical hacker is
aware of the local security laws and
standards why is that because an
organization cannot do any illegal
activity whatever responses that they
have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
Implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause and
you have to any of the employees or any
of the third party clients that they are
dealing with so the ethical hacker
should be aware of what security laws
are before they Implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming it's good to have
a certification in PHP pull python Ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize in their testing scenarios to be
honest there are hundreds of tools out
there what you see on the screen as just
a few examples of them uh nessus is a
vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified and
the scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners like acunetics or Arachne that
would help you scan applications and
identify flaws within those applications
as well now all of these are automated
tools the essence of ethical hacker is
when these tools churn out the reports
the ethical hacker can understand these
reports analyze them identify the flaws
and then craft their own exploits or use
existing exploits in a particular manner
so that they can get access or they can
bypass the access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
Metasploit you see that that Big M there
on the right hand side that M logo is
for a tool called Metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where Metasploit helps us do that
Wireshark would be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or Metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever I run a necess scanner I
would run a Wireshark in the background
it will capture the data packets and I
can go through those data packets and
analyze that data package to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when I try to attack a machine
using exploit on Metasploit I will keep
on Wireshark running in the background
to capture the data package that have
been sent and the responses that I've
received from the victim so that I can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and basically
it will also give me a validation of
proof of the activity that has happened
nmap is another automated tool that
allows me to scan for open ports and
protocols so why would I use nmap
because Pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect
through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 is using https so if
I'm connecting to a web server using
https it is safe to assume that Port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those actions similarly there would be
other services that may be left open on
the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there is a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automated tool called SQL
map or SQL map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a SQL injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here I do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the SQL map
tool would automatically create them for
me what I would do is I would use Nexus
to identify that particular flaw if
nessus reports that flaw I will would
then go use the tool SQL map configure
it to attack that particular web server
and when I fire off the tool it will
then automatically start directing
queries SQL injection queries to the
database to see if those databases are
vulnerable and if yes what data can be
retrieved from those databases so all of
these tools in a nutshell would help me
hack networks applications operating
systems and host devices and this is
what ethical hacker does they use these
kind of tool sets they identify what
attacks they need to do they identify
the right tool for that particular
attack and they write their exploits
they create those attacks and then they
start attacking analyze the response and
then give a report to the management
providing them feedback about how the
attack was created or crafted what was
the response to that attack and whether
the attack was successful or not if
successful they would also give
recommendations of what to do to prevent
these attacks from happening in the
future so when we are doing these
attacks or when we want to launch these
attacks what is the process that we
would follow so there are six steps that
we would do as an ethical hacker if you
are just a hacker you probably wouldn't
do the sixth step which is a reporting
step so the first step that would be
done is the reconnaissance phase which
is the information gathering phase which
is very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the nasus
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
akinetics for applications and then I
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once I have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that I may have found
during the scanning phase once I have
gained my access I want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody we
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist existing or
somebody changed the password that we
have I may have cracked thus I no longer
have access so what do I do to maintain
my access I installed Trojans or
backdoor entries to those systems using
which I can secretly in a covert manner
get access to those devices at my own
will at my own time as long as those
devices are available over the network
so that's where I maintain my access I
have hacked them now I want to maintain
my access so I install a software which
would give me a backdoor entry to that
device no matter what once I have done
this I want to clear my track so
whatever activity that I've been doing
for example installing a Trojan a Trojan
is also a software that would create
directory directories and files once
installed on the victims machine so I
want to hide that if I have access data
stores if I have modified data I want to
hide that activity because if the victim
comes to know that something has
happened they would start they would
start increasing their security
parameters they might start scanning
their devices they may take them offline
does my hack would no longer be
efficient the reason I'm clearing my
tracks is that the victim doesn't find
out that they have been hacked or they
have been compromised or even if they do
find out that they've been compromised
they cannot trace the compromise back to
me so I would be deleting references of
any of the IP addresses or Mac addresses
that I may have used to attack that
particular device and this is where I
will be able to identify where those
logs were created where those traces are
once I take off those traces the victim
would not be any wiser of whether they
have been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack I'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that ethical hacking process would take
uh just going through this recognizance
is where you're going to use hiking
tools like nmap HP to obtain information
about targets there are hundreds of
tools out there depending on what
information you want then in scanning
again nmap next pose these kind of tools
to be utilized to identify open ports
protocols and services in gaining access
you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the Metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install backdoors
you can use meta square at the same time
you can craft your own scripts to create
Trojan and install it on the victim's
machine once you have achieved that
clearing tracks is where you're going to
clear all evidences of your activity so
that you do not get caught or the victim
doesn't even realize that they have been
hacked and once you have done all of
this we are going to create reports that
are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand the
current security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen phishing activity what is
phishing we receive a lot of frequents
on a regular basis we have always
received those emails where we have won
a lottery of a few million dollars but
we have never realized that we didn't
purchase a lot to win a lottery in the
first place we have always had those
Nigerian frauds where a prince died in
some South African country and you out
of 7 billion people on the planet have
been identified where they want to
transfer a few hundred million dollars
through your account and they want to
give you 50 of that money in return as
thank you so some very basic attacks
where you go on to websites and there's
a banner flashing at you saying
congratulations you're the one millionth
visitor to this website click here to
claim your price all of these are social
engineering attacks phishing attacks
fake websites fake Communications being
sent out to users to prey on their
gullibility most of humans always have
that dream of striking it rich winning a
huge Lottery once and for all and living
their life lavishly ever after but sadly
in the real world that's not that
doesn't happen that often and if you're
receiving those meals it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with the
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
I do not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack we
it would be easily be able to uh gather
the information that you have set for
your security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
cool that you attended you probably have
that listed on your LinkedIn profile
where a person can just go in there and
see your academic qualifications and
identify the school that you're in right
similarly it might also be a question
what was your mother's maiden name
that's a very good attack and that's uh
I mean if a person can interact with you
let's say they are trying to take a
survey and approach you for a feedback
on a particular product that you have
been utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is open
a generic attack whoever Falls victim
will fall victim so if I just throw
around a few USBS in the parking lot
obviously with Trojans implemented on
them some people who are curious or who
are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in there those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed we just talked about the Nigerian
frauds and the lotteries those kind of
attacks the fake money making gimmicks
now basically this is where you Prey
Upon the person's agreed kicking in and
they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we
are going to send the key to the end
user the you end user using this same
key would then decrypt that data if
anybody compromises that data while it
is being sent over the network since it
is encrypted they would not be able to
read it so the encryption algorithm
would be something like this now if you
see uh the computer word once made into
unreadable format would look like eqor
xvgt for an end user it wouldn't make
any sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer and then
understand the meaning of that word so
this is just a substitution Cipher that
is being shown on the screen so what is
the alphabet the key is alphabet plus
three so C plus three alphabets that
becomes e o becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilized to scramble the
data is the character that you are at
the third character from there would be
the corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom to the hacker would you so it is
now your prerogative of how you're going
to work around and how you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to decrypt that
message and see what's within it right
decryption without the use of a secret
key that is known as a crypt analysis
Crypt analysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out what the
decryption was without using a key so
Crypt analysis can be done using various
formats the first one is a Brute Force
attack second is a dictionary attack
third one is a rainbow table attack a
Brute Force attack is trying every
combination permutation and combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful but may take a
lot of time a dictionary attack is where
you have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out the similarities between between the
text that you have and the encrypted
data that you wanted to decrypt in the
first place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tant amount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the ciphertext
is compared with another Cipher text you
find out similarities and then you try
to work a reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we end this
section so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammy.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
I say I want to encode a message I turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one and it will convert that into
a spam mail you send it across so
whoever is reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if I want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is ASD at the right
one two three four and I want to send
this out to people or to one of my
colleagues but I want to send it out in
a secret manner so that others are not
aware of this so when I press on encode
what the algorithm would do is it will
convert this message into a spam mail so
my message hi this is a secret message
the password is at the rate one two
three four or ASG at the rate one two
three four gets converted into this now
if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
I've already sent so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open up a new browser and I'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time I am going to click on decode
when I click on decode and going to
paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the Google Chrome
browser and in the Firefox browser we
decoded similarly if I want to protect
these kind of messages there is an
aspenencrypt.com website where let's say
we use text encryption and I want to
encrypt the same message this is a
secret message the password is ASD at
the rate1234 and then I give it a
password to protect this message let's
say the word password and I use the
cipher to scramble this by using let's
say AES which is the strongest Cipher
right now and I say encrypt so this is
what the encryption would look like and
basically if I don't have the password
over here if I decrypt it you would see
that there it has occurred now if I type
in the password over here and then
decrypt it it will be able to convert
that back into the unscrambled text and
it will give me what the original
message was this is a secret message the
password is ASD at the rate one two
three four so if I want to keep my data
secure from hackers I want to scramble
it in such a way that they would not be
able to crack it or it would be very
difficult from for them to crack it and
this is one of the first mechanisms that
would be recommended by any ethical
hacker to keep the data secure now let's
talk about downloading and installing
Kali Linux along with that we'll also be
looking at the basic commands that are
required for Kali Linux all right so
I've opened my browser and we want to go
to the Kali website so we want to go to
kali.org you can directly type in
kali.org and go to the website I can
just do a Google Search and say Kali
download and it will give you the same
website but it will directly take you to
the downloads pages so either here and
or you can go to the home page cookies
are being installed on your machine so
see which cookies you want to allow I'm
only going to use the necessary cookies
to support this site and you can see
that this gives you the latest Kali
Linux news and tutorials gives you the
latest release what is in that release
and gives you a lot of documentation
which will help you understand what
tools have been developed and what
functionality has been given in the
latest version if you want to download
you can directly go here and you can
download Kali Linux now Kali Linux is a
2.6 gigabyte download so it's going to
take time the latest version being
2019.4 and we click over here I'm using
a download manager to manage all these
huge downloads and you can see it's
pointed to the operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 GB download
so you click on download and in the
background uh you can see this is going
to be downloaded and you're going to
minimize this and it will take a few
minutes for that to download but this is
an ISO image so we need to install it on
a virtual machine so what we need is we
need to use a hypervisor which will
allow us to create virtual machines so
we can either use VMware Workstation
which you can download from here however
this is paid version so you can see it
is around 250 or something for uh this
software but it is a very good software
to have so if you click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period if you want to use
it after 30 days you'll need to enter
the key which you will get after
purchasing the software if you do not
want to utilize this the free version
that you have you can either download
VMware Player but there are some
limitations for VMware Player that you
might want to look at does you want to
compare these products before you want
to purchase them right otherwise you can
download Oracle virtualbox which is a
free hypervisor it's not as robust as
VMware Workstation but it does the trick
right so the the free version 6.1 is
free and you can then create your own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them what I do have
I already have a VMware Workstation
installed so I'm just going to open that
up and that's my VMware Workstation as
you can see I already have a lot of
virtual machines created over here what
we're going to do is we are going to
configure a virtual machine for the Kali
Linux operating system that we are
downloading which should be somewhere
here let's see it's at 43 percent so all
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so I click click on file
create a new virtual machine I am going
to customize the machine so click on
next this will be default we don't want
to change that and then we want to
install the operating system later we
don't want to point it out right now so
I'll just click on I will install the
operating system later click on next we
want to install Linux now in the drop
down you would not see Kali Linux over
here however you can choose Uber 1 to
64-bit that's what I'm going to choose
there it is next what is the name that
we want I want to give it Kali Linux
without the typo and I want to store it
in one of the folders that I created by
default it stores on the C drive which
is not a good place to store uh you
don't want to run out of space on your C
drive so I'm going to click on this PC
and this is my data and in here I'll
have a folder called virtualbox or
virtual machines there it is within
which you can see the other softwares
that I already created I'm going to
create a new folder and call it Kali
2019 l l for is latest for me because
you can see already have a Kali Linux so
I'm just going to identify this folder
with the L at the end I'm going to
select it and click on okay you can see
the path being changed over here click
on next it's going to ask you how many
processors now depending on the
processor that you have you can see I've
got a 8 core i7 so if I give it 16 cores
or 16 processors that's not going to
work I cannot go beyond what the
physicality already is so for this
machine One processor with one core is
more than enough if you're going to use
a lot of tools at the same time you
might just want to give it two cores so
you're given it two cores it will ask us
for Ram to be provided for this Virtual
Machine by default 2048 megabytes that's
2GB of RAM is more than enough if you
require more we can change this later on
so click on next we want to use Nat for
now leave this default next whatever is
recommended keep it the way it is we do
not want to change it next create a new
virtual hard disk for this machine and
it is going to ask us the size 20 GB is
more than fine store it as a single file
we don't want to use multiple file
options click on next and then click on
browse wherever you want to store the
vmdk file or the virtual hard disk file
and we go back again to the same folder
that we had created virtual machines and
we look at the Kali Linux Kali 2019l and
we want to store the vmdk file over
there once we save it you want to click
on next and then we want to click on
finish so this is the virtual machine
that has been created right here right
now this is the basic configuration now
where are we at with the operating
system and you can see the operating
system has been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so you
go to e Drive so we're looking for the
operating system that we have downloaded
we downloaded in the operating systems
folder and if we go in here you can see
the current one the Kali Linux 2019.4
ISO right here so what we do we go back
to the Kali Linux machine that we have
created edit virtual machine settings
and we point this virtual machine using
the CD DVD and then we point the iso the
one that we downloaded over here so we
go back to e Drive we go back to OS and
we click on Kali Linux 2019 click on
open so now when this boots up it will
boot up with this ISO and then it will
allow us to install the operating system
so click on OK then we click on power on
this virtual machine it will start
powering on it it will boot to the iso
and it will start giving us the booting
options so I'm just going to enter the
full screen mode over here for this to
be better visible and we don't want the
live mode what we want is we want to use
the graphical install and then we
highlight that we press enter and you
can see the setup starting up we'll wait
for the GUI to pop up there it is which
language do we want for now we want
English click on continue where are we
located click on continue and the
configure your keyboard we want the US
keyboard American English continue it is
going to detect the hardware so as you
can see on the screen it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these
settings the network with DHCP it has
identified the network cards Hardware
like the processor that has been
provided or is asking for a host name
we're going to leave it at default we're
going to click on continue domain name
I'm not joining this into a domain as
yet there's going to be a standalone
machine so I can leave this blank click
on continue cloud is going to configure
the network it is asking for a password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the username for the
account is the name is the word root we
are just creating the password for the
root account and then we want to click
on continue setting of The Clock looking
at the hard disks now here it asks us do
we want to use the entire disk the 20gb
virtual hard disk that we had provided
or do we want to give it a manual
configuration or a guided one where we
want encryption analogical volume
management coming into the picture we're
just going to use the first option
guided you use entire disk don't worry
it's only going to use the virtual disk
that we had created click on continue it
will give us that it's a 21.5 GB VMware
virtual disk that we had and click on
continue all files in one partition
that's what we want recommended for new
users whatever it is we don't want to
change these folders continue and this
is what we have configured once we click
on continue it is going to say you are
you sure you want to make these changes
click on yes click on continue and it
will start installing Kali Linux on your
device now this is going to take a few
minutes for the installation to work all
right so that's the installation that's
completed now it's asking us to
configure a package manager a network
mirror can be used to supplement the
software that is included on the
installation media this may also make
new versions of software available you
want to use a network mirror we can
click no for now and then click on
continue now this is going to install
the grub bootloader this might take a
few minutes as well install the group
grub loader to the master boot record
yes click on continue click the hard
disk that you have just utilized this is
the one click on continue it will
install the grub bootloader running
through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and you can see this is
starting up so we are going to you you
just wait out the boot and now it
started the booting sequence is going to
maximize the screen and you can see it's
asking me for the password this is the
one that we created now that's the
that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on login
and this is your screen uh now what we
need to do here is we need to install
VMware tools which will help us manage
the screen and help the virtual machine
to be a little bit better integrated on
the system so that's not mounted yet so
we're just waiting for it to Mount there
it is and what we want to do here is
open VMware tools upgrader all right so
what we want is we want to extract or we
want to use this openx archiver and once
we do that we'll see the VMware
install.pl double click on that all
right we've got the VMware tools here
what I've done is we have extract two
and I've extracted that on the desktop
right so what we just did was click on
the desktop over here open and this is
what it will do and click on extract now
there is happening because I've already
extracted this open this up we want to
run this VMware install dot PL so what
do we do we open up the terminal window
which is the command line interface over
here and now this is where some of the
commands come into the picture so for
example PWD it will show us the present
working directory LS will show us the
list of the folders that are there so
the folder that we have is on our
desktop so we'll just change directory
to desktop press enter do an LS that
will show us the list and you can see
VMware tools this trip that's the folder
that we have right here right so we want
to go into that folder CD VMware at this
point you can just click on Tab and it
will populate everything over there
press enter do an LS and we want the VM
where hyphen install dot PL to be
executed all right so we tried executing
that command we had an error over there
so what we need to do is we need to
execute this command so dot slash VMware
in a hyphen install.pl and we'll start
creating now it will ask you for your
input installing VMware Tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files by default it is going to
see you slash USR slash bin if I just
press enter it is going to use the
default as you can see the input over
here what directory do you want the any
directories I'm just going to press keep
on pressing enter for the defaults to
come in this part does not exist it is
going to create it default yes defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it to maximize the screen
and this is where it is installing and
you can see by just installing that it
automatically adjusted the screen and
now we got a full screen of Kali Linux
right here right and that is what VMware
tools does for us once we have installed
the operating system and now we can see
the entire screen on here you will see
the tool sets that are given here now
why are we using Kali Linux in the first
place because this comes in with a
bundle of thousands of softwares that
are ready to be utilized for ethical
hacking right and they have been
categorized over here for information
gathering vulnerability analysis web
application analysis and so on so forth
so you can see for forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
Graphics coming in Internet and the
system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are writing on the
favorites if I click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got scarter and map
fuzzing tools web application analysis
we have got comics skip fish SQL map
database assessments password attacks
and so on so forth so if you just go in
the favorites this was the terminal
emulator that we utilized this is the
command line that we saw we use the CD
command we use the PWD command we did
the ls command as well to give us the
list of of the directory that we are in
similarly there would be commands like
cat so let's go to CD downloads let's
see what the uh what's there you can see
this case sensitive so if I type in a
capital D and then do a tab LS there's
nothing over here on download so CD dot
dot will take us back One Directory now
you can see we are back from downloads
to root if I want to go to desktop this
is how I go to desktop do a LS you can
see the VMware tools uh folder over
there CD VMware tools and we go into
that folder LS which will give us the
list of all those files now you can see
install is a file that we had edited
back then so if I do a cat install you
will see the cat basically is the
command that will help us look at the
contents of the file all right without
opening up the file or without editing
the file so you can see just if I scroll
up this is where we give the cat command
it then uh printed the contents of the
file over here and then it exited and
gave me back to command line right here
right if I I want to copy this CP root
desktop VMware install and if you want
to copy it to root downloads and press
enter now what we are going to do is we
are going to see if this file the
install file that we just edited over
here has been copied to the downloads
folder so we do us we are currently in
the VMware on the desktop VMware tools
District folder video CD dot dot that
takes us down One Directory so we are
still in the desktop do a CD dot dot now
you can see we are back in the root and
now we are going to do a CD downloads
and LS and you can see the copied file
right here so if I do a cat install you
can see the same content of that file
coming in so these are some of the
commands that we would need to learn as
we go ahead the remove command is let's
say we've got install we do a man RM man
is the manual page command that gives us
the pages with the description of how
that particular command is to be used
like so RMS remove files or directories
synopsis the description the options
hyphen f for Force hyphen I for prompt
hyphen capital I prompt ones before
removing more than three files and so on
so forth if you want to exit this you
can press Q to exit and you come back to
this page so if I say RM install LS
you'll see that the install file has now
been deleted so in Windows we use the
Del Dell command in Linux it is the RM
command so this is what we wanted to
look at the demo for Kali Linux how to
download it how to install it and some
of the basic commands that we can
utilize all right let's begin with the
phishing tutorial we have the Kali Linux
operating system booted up over here uh
what we're going to do is we are going
to open up a tool called set social
engineering toolkit which you would find
in this option and that's the tool that
we want it's a command line tool a menu
driven tool we are going to host a fake
Facebook page and you can see how we can
Harvest credentials by this kind of an
attack so these are some disclaimers you
might want to go through that do you
want to agree to the terms of service
yes press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are talking
about a phishing attack which can comes
under the social engineering attack so
it like I said it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the number of the
option that we want so we want to do a
social engineering attack so I type in
one press enter and that it is asking me
whether I want a spear phishing attack a
website attack Vector we are going to
choose a second option so I type in two
press enter and then it asks me uh what
I want to do I want to take the third
option here credential Harvester attack
methodology and we want to do the third
attack now it is asking whether we want
to use the in-house website templates
that it already has or do we want to
clone a site or do we have a customized
site that we have prepared that we want
to migrate into this tool we are going
to do the site cloning option so we're
going to type in two press enter and
then it is going to ask me the IP
address where it wants to capture and
store the credentials by default this is
the IP address that I'm using so if I
leave it blank it will take my default
IP address so I'm just going to press
enter and now it is asking me the URL to
clone so I type in HTTPS
www.facebook.com what it is going to do
it is going to correct online and it is
now because let us clone the website
Facebook login.php the best way to use
this attack is that you if you use the
if the username and password form are in
the same field or the same page
regardless this captures all posts on a
website so you may need to copy www star
into HTML depending on where your
directory structure is press return if
you understand what we are seeing here
so press enter the social engine toolkit
credential Harvest attack is running on
Port 80 information will be displayed to
you as it arrives so the site was 71.134
4 right the default IP address and this
is where the website is being hosted
let's check that out so let me open up a
browser on my host machine and let me
point it to the Kali Linux machine that
we have just created
192.168.71.134 and you should see a
login to Facebook coming up right here
looks genuine it is genuine because we
just went online and downloaded this
let's just have a recap let's have an
explanation of what we are trying to do
I am trying to host fake Facebook page
on my server which has an embedded
script in it which is going to do
credential harvesting so the attack here
is let's say if I have now hosted this I
can craft a fake email send it across to
a victim saying uh your Facebook account
has seen some unforeseen activity create
a hyperlink using HTML coding within
that click here to access your account
and verify uh that the account is
secured and when they click on that link
they will be redirected to my fake page
which is here you can see the IP
addresses my virtual machines IP address
but I'm seeing a Facebook login page and
I'm going to type in someone at
somewhere.com and the password I'm just
going to type in the regular ones that I
use and if you see it when we typed in
uh the username and password the page
just refreshed and gave us the login
page again but now if you look at the
URL I'm actually on Facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that I
was hosting so a lemon wouldn't probably
figure out they've been hacked by now
they just would figure out okay they
probably typed in the incorrect password
and the page refresh or something like
that and they're just going to log in
and they're actually going to access the
Facebook page thus they might not even
realize that something went wrong but if
I go back to my virtual machine you can
see that it has captured some data and
it is reporting over here of what has
happened so if I just scroll up let's
see what happened here and if you have
been able to capture anything so we got
a hit printing the output this does the
HTTP 1.1 200 okay response coming in
password field phone and we're just
looking there it is email someone at
somewhere.com and password that I typed
in ASD at the rate one two three four so
it has captured the username and the
password right here uh once you're done
I mean this is the way attackers work
now this is a very basic attack again uh
in the actual trainings you would then
look at how you would Host this on a
real website make it a global attack
right now it's a virtual machine with a
class CIP address so here the thought
processors where can we get a free
hosting where we can host this kind of
sites maybe I'll have to purchase a
domain which looks like similar to
Facebook or the victim that I'm trying
to attack so this is just a POC so we
just wanted to find out if we can how
phishing is done and this is exactly how
it is done right so pressing Ctrl C
would exit this tool and takes you back
to the actual menu press 99 99 to exit
and there it is close the two window and
that's the fishing practical after
fishing let's talk about SQL injection
SQL injection stands for uh structured
query language injection which is a
database attack though it resides within
the application so is the application
vulnerability that you're trying to look
at to try to bypass authentication as
the name suggests a SQL induction over
limited allows an attacker to inject
malicious input into a SQL statement
what is a SQL statement a query that is
used by an application and is fired off
to the database database executes that
query uh gets that information that is
required and sends it back to the user
if the user is authenticated so we're
going to look at the SQL injection
attack demo here and what we're going to
do is we are going to go back to our
VMware Workstation and I've got a tool
over here called ovasc Brooklyn web
application which is a utility that has
been created for people like us to test
our skills to learn on how we can
develop our skills further so this has a
lot of vulnerable applications built
within it we're just going to try to
access it and we are going to see if we
can create a SQL injection attack just
waiting for it to boot up once it boots
up it will give us an IP address there
we are so we need to connect to 71.132
so I can just use the same browser I was
using close up Facebook and now go to
192 168
71.132 and this is the ovas broken web
application project uh what we're going
to do is we are going to go to utility
day and this is a application that has a
lot of information within it you can see
it gives you links about what you should
do help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now I'm just going to do
this as a demo show what we're going to
do is we are going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in I'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechan is them works now
what we want to do is we want to create
a query now what does a query look like
when I type in a username and a password
if I just type in a single port here it
is going to create an error and this is
what a SQL query looks like so like
username from account where username is
a single code and then the exception
error happens so it's not showing the
rest of the query to us now what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to craft a
query here a single quote and give it a
condition or one equals one space hyphen
iPhone space What Happens hyphen hyphen
space is comments out anything after
that so the password field is being
commented out at this point in time and
I'm just giving it a condition where the
condition is true 1 does equal 1 and if
this condition is true it is going to
allow me to log in so you can see right
now we are not logged in this bypasses
the authentication mechanism and you can
see user authenticated and we are now
logged in as admin so in the training
what we need to understand as a whole is
how SQL Works what are the queries that
are structured with how you can what are
the test operators now the single code
that we used that was an operator in the
SQL syntax what these operators are how
they function and then how you can
leverage these attacks there are
different tools that are given to you in
Kali as well that you can utilize so in
Kali Linux you can just open up a
command prompt and there's a tool called
SQL map you need to give it a particular
site so SQL map hyphen U for the URL and
whatever the URL is now URL here and
then once you're here you just press the
enter key this tool will craft all the
queries in the background for you you
don't even have to nosql query or SQL
languages this is a very easy tool to
utilize sadly I cannot demo this on a
live website because that would be
illegal but you can see how you can
operate this yourself that's what SQL
injections are all about moving on we
now talk about uh vpns virtual private
networks and a virtual private network
is basically a secure network that
allows me to anonymize myself over the
Internet so what I'm doing is I'm
connecting from here to a server that
encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and thus allows me to keep my
data secure now the basic essence of a
VPN or a virtual private network is to
allow me this encryption mechanism where
I can encrypt and Safeguard my data the
added advantage that nowadays a VPN
gives is that they can allow us to spoof
our IP address or obfuscate our IP
address so we can actually become
Anonymous on the internet it can allow
us to use multiple IP addresses and thus
secure ourselves on the internet for
example I use VPN called cyberghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here and if you
look at the entire list all the servers
then there are no spy servers which can
guarantee me that they are not going to
keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that I'm doing right since they
are located out Romania this becomes a
little bit more safer for me because the
government and the laws over there are a
little bit more relaxed than other
countries uh they give me different
links for torrenting for streaming for
connection feature so uh there are a lot
of vpns out there so for example let's
go to the website cyberghost.com so we
can see there's a sale going on 76
percent sale or you can go on to
expressvpn which is also a very good VP
and then there is not VPN it depends on
what uh you want and how you want to
utilize it so just purchasing a VPN or
getting a free free VPN is not enough it
depends on which country the VPN
originates from and which server you're
connected to for example most of the
countries have a pact where they share
information amongst themselves even if
you're connected to a VPN that means
that these companies that provide these
Services have to generate and store logs
and these logs have to be reported to
the government if they ask for it now if
there's a list of 14 countries that
actually focuses on this practice so you
have to find out VPN that and a server
that is not a part of those 14 countries
and ensure that those logs are not going
to be reported to the government and
these are three vpns basically are
something that which are good and I
personally use cyberghost I've used
others I just keep on rotating them just
to get an idea of which one is better so
these are vpns that you can allow you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on uh these are the ones that we
talked about there are other safer VPN
hide my ass expressvpn and so on so
forth from our terminologies let's now
talk about VPS VPS is basically virtual
private server where you can rent a
service or server as a service a virtual
machine as a service so basically on a
cloud using infrastructure as a service
you can rent a server and utilize it for
whatever activity you want so let's go
to these sites register.com God ID
Network Solutions or we can talk about
other Cloud Solutions as well so here
you can get register your domain names
uh so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about the phishing
exercise uh what we want is we can go on
to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com and we can purchase a
particular domain for example something
like this instead of the O's I'm typing
in a couple of zeros for the Facebook
and see let's see if anything of that is
available now something dot photo is
available or facetips.com is available
uh there are other options that are
making over here that they're giving us
over here and once we purchase this we
can then have our own hosting uh with a
web hosting as a service and we can have
a Linux based hosting or a Windows based
hosting depending on what you want and
that's where your shared hosting comes
with the picture if you just want uh if
you want to look at a virtual server and
you want to rent a server over there
itself you can move on to rackspace.com
and here in your services you can have
physical server or a virtual server in a
public Cloud your other Cloud providers
for example would be Amazon AWS and on
AWS you can basically look at ec2
elastic compute Cloud which is basically
virtual servers in the cloud and over
here you can rent out a server with
whatever capacity you require you'll
obviously have to pay the rent for what
those servers are going to cost but once
you have those servers you can then
launch any services on top of it uh
looking at other services that we have
we talked about Tor tar is a onion
routing software that allows users to
browse the web anonymously so we can
just go online and we can try to spoof
our identity and I'm going to show you
how so I've got a VMware Workstation
right here the one so we're just going
to pull that up and we're going to power
on a Windows 7 machine where we are
going to look at the onion routing so
Windows machine has booted up we're just
going to log in and this is my Windows 7
machine now I've got a Chrome browser
right here and we're going to go to a
website called see myip.com which is
going to give the IP address that I'm
currently using so right now I'm not on
connected to any VPN or anything and you
can see that's my IP address that I'm
utilizing now if I want to anonymize
myself what I'm going to do is I am
going to use Tor and that's the Tor
Browser that's set up right there if I
click on it it's going to open up the
software and it's going to create a new
network and it's going to connect to the
tornetwork and allow me to anonymize
myself right so that's the top browser
opening up and giving me a new browser
over here so I've got one which is the
old one which is my current IP address
if I just refresh that you'll see that
I'm still on the same IP address as far
as this browser is concerned there's a
refresh and it's still showing you the
same IP address where if I go on to Thor
right now and if I go to see my ip.com
you will see that it is going to give me
and you can see the amount of time it is
taking to reach that site that's because
I am using a VPN and there's a lot of
encryption running off and you can see
now I'm certainly connected via Hong
Kong and even to reach this site what
Tor does is it gives me a proxy chain a
proxy chain is where it creates multiple
hops to hide my identity and before I
reach see my ip.com I am using three
different IP addresses over here one in
France one in Germany and one in Hong
Kong so if I do something over here to
trace back my steps to my actual IP
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who's going to search like a
forensic investigator would have to go
through these IP addresses before they
come back to me now it's not impossible
but the effort and time that's going to
be taken to come across three different
countries is going to be phenomenal so
it may just defeat the purpose of having
so much resources spent to identify who
did what so that's what taught does for
us all right moving on from Tor you're
going to look at Key loggers key loggers
are basically softwares that run in the
background and record all the keystrokes
of the user so if I've got a keylogger
installed right now whatever I type will
be stored in a text file for the hacker
so that they can look at it later on and
just to give you an example of that we
go back to my VMware Workstation and we
open up another Windows 7 machine I'm
going to power this on and I'm going to
close this one to them so this virtual
machine has booted up we are going to
use user One login as user one just
close all these softwares which are not
required and once this machine is booted
up what we're going to do is I'm just
going to open up a random websites and
see what we're doing basically there's a
keylogger that's there in the startup
that's going to record our keystrokes
and we just want to see what it actually
does now Firefox is getting updated so
let's hold on now this is the latest
version of Firefox right and you're just
going to go to let's say facebook.com
column we've got a website to open up
all right let's try opening it up again
and that's facebook.com and we're just
going to type in some random username
and passwords somewhere someone at
somewhere.com and the password being
again ASD at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero login
obviously that login is not going to
work user probably doesn't exist or if
it does the password probably is
incorrect and uh so we're going to close
this uh we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site uh
rediff.com and then go to rediffmail try
the same thing over here someone at
somewhere.com password USD
31234567 whatever it is don't say we can
see the combination is incorrect now
there's a key logger running in the
background and what we want is we now
want to open up the keylogger now it is
visible here because I've kept it
visible you can hide it in the start
menu and there's a shortcut tricky for
you to pull it up later on so this
completely becomes invisible and what it
can do is it basically creates a record
of whatever you have been doing so far
so you can see these things populating
on the 25th of December so if I look at
the visited website you can see I opened
up Mozilla Firefox the first where it uh
there was a problem loading the page
then we opened up Facebook then we
opened up rediffmail.com and so on so
forth so this it just gives me the list
of visited websites whereas if I look at
Key stocks and clipboard you will see
whatever we have typed in so we first
typed in facebook.com then again uh the
second time I try try to type in then I
hit backspace then I type in
facebook.com and then you can see I
typed in someone at somewhere.com and in
tab ASD at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero we closed
up the browser we opened up a new one
and we went on to rediffmail.com and
then you can see me typing this one then
going back one space then the rest of
what I typed and then the password
coming in so that's what a keylogger
does if you look at the taskbar it's not
going to show you a keylogger running in
the background it's in processes you're
not going to see anything at all but
it's going to mask itself as a service
so if you look into the properties you
can see that icon coming in over here
which matches this one and so you can
see that this masking itself as a
service.exe if this gets hidden as well
it would be very difficult for a user to
even identify this all right so that's
what a keylogger is moving on let's see
what else we want to talk about so we've
talked about or we have talked about
keyloggers and now we want to talk about
firewalls now for keyloggers to be
prevented we need antiviruses right so
we need a good antivirus program that's
going to be installed updated and run on
a regular basis to protect ourselves
from malware but what about network
connections and you need a firewall and
a system to prevent or to detect what
kind of connections are going on in the
first place now we cannot rely on
software as 100 so even if a firewall is
not configured properly at that's that's
going to be a problem so what we need to
do is we have to have a firewall
configure it correctly and then allow
and this allow certain activity from off
happening and what we are going to do is
I've got such a system on my machine
here I use a software called glasswire
what it does is it is a network analyzer
so it allows me to analyze whatever is
going on you can see all the apps that
I'm utilizing and how much upload and
download they have been doing all the
traffic so you can see the protocols
that I'm utilizing so I come to know
what's going on in the background and
this gives me the entire graph of how
much I have been doing for the past 24
hours past 3 hours past five minutes and
so on so forth right so this is what the
activities and these are the alerts that
it has been generating I can click on
those alert and it will start telling me
what it was all about if the graph
doesn't work for me it gives me usage as
well so how much I have utilized since
I've installed this software right and
what applications have been utilized
which hosts have been connected to and
the traffic type that was utilized and
then the things on my network so these
are the devices that I have currently on
my network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified and again just
click on a particular service to lock
that service so this becomes a discovery
tool identifies whatever networking is
going on gives me all that information
and then I can look at and I can just
click on any of these services that I
find it as malicious and block them I
can create different profiles for
different applications as I'm as and
when I want them and these are the
alerts so you can see that this was the
first time a network connection was
looked at from VMware and what this
allows me to do is whenever I execute a
file it can upload it to virus total.com
and scan it as a third party antivirus
to ensure that there is nothing
malicious on it so I already have an
antivirus over here but if this ever
gets compromised I still can rely on a
third-party service where I'm real time
as an and when I execute my applications
uh they would be verified and I would be
a sure that nothing is wrong with my
system and this software that I'm
utilizing glassware basic is free and
then there are paid versions as well it
says glasswire.com is where you're going
to find this moving on rootkit root kits
are also malicious softwares that you
allow an unauthorized user to have
access to a computer to restrict areas
of its software now a rootkit in is a
sensors which a software a malicious
software that infects a machine and
prevents a some functionality from it
like hiding data or preventing users
from running antiviruses and it's
basically a malicious software that is
used to hide information from the victim
so that they would not realize that they
have actually been compromised it's
going to be a difficult showing of a
root kit so I cannot show that demo to
you so we're just going to move on and
we are going to talk about ethical
hacking techniques now now when we say
ethical hacking techniques we want to
look at what kind of audits are
available when we want to do ethical
hacking so there's a black box audit a
white box audit and a gray box audit so
if I'm invited in an organization to
conduct a test to conduct a audit to
conduct a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they're not going to tell me about
the infrastructure they're not going to
give me any information and they want me
to start from the basics of gathering
information identifying the systems and
based on the information that I gather
whether I'm able to develop any hacks
and compromise their infrastructure so
it will be a simulation of a hacker
who's sitting outside the organization
and trying to find a way in whereas a
white box audit is where full
infrastructure knowledge is given
anything and everything that is required
for an audit is given and this is a
simulation of an Insider attack a person
sitting inside the organization misusing
their permissions and then trying to
compromise trying to get access to data
that they do not have access to so the
simulation is from a malicious Insider a
gray boxes where some partial knowledge
is available and from that partial
knowledge you're going to try to build
up more information and then you are
going to try to get access to those
resources what are the tools that we
utilize so we have already had a couple
of demos on keyloggers SQL injection SQL
map and so on so forth Metasploit is uh
very much used tool for penetration
testing and uh having knowledge on my
task light is very much necessary as far
as ethical hacking is concerned nmap
this is a tool used for network
discovery message a vulnerability
scanner Wireshark is a packet capturer
that allows you to capture packets and
analyze whatever is going on SQL map is
something that we have seen a SQL
injection attack tool which generates
its own queries and John the Ripper is a
password cracking Tool uh backtrack used
to be an operating system that was
utilized for penetration testing however
backtrack has now been replaced by
something called Kali Linux and that's
the operating system that we have
utilized in all our demos where we try
to look at SQL map and those injection
attacks that we did so what are the
areas of ethical hacking we have just
talked about all these areas as well
Network Services we looked at the
glassware application that showed us how
my machine is consuming networks which
Protocols are being consumed how the
connections are being created if
somebody is able to install a Trojan on
my machine it is going to try to create
a new connection on the network with the
hacker to allow that hacker a back door
access now if I have that glass wire or
a similar firewall implemented it is
this wire wall that is going to detect
it and prevent that connection from
happening so if I install a software
that is suddenly suspicious or that
installs something else in the
background that I may not be aware of
that tool is going to identify all the
connections that are being made and it
is going to highlight that connection I
need to go through all of those
connections and identify whether they
are legit or not and if I find some
suspicious or doubtful I am going to
block that connection and then I'm going
to investigate what's going on and
that's where ethical hacking comes into
the picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configure of the firewall is done
properly or if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some SQL
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a vulnerability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access to
resources that we were not authorized
for and then client-side attacks should
be where uh you install keylogger at the
end of the at the client system and then
you try to capture whatever data the
user is typing in like usernames and
passwords on the Facebook and the
redefmail.com website that we saw and
then try to misuse that information to
get access to those resources then Wi-Fi
networks right Wi-Fi is something that
we use on a regular basis we got a smart
devices nowadays smartphones tablets
phablets that we can connect to Wi-Fi
and start using all our services our
banking applications and our smartphones
and thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secured so
you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones antiviruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you are utilizing is going to remain
secure and in Social Engineering we've
looked at the phishing website on
facebook.com you've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and host them on
Apache server so if you look at it as a
from ethical hackers perspective the job
of ethical hacker is to simulate these
kind of attacks that a hacker May
conduct and first of all you're
basically going to find out areas where
these attacks can happen think of it
from a hacker's perspective try to
simulate those attacks and see if those
attacks are going to be effective can
those attacks be prevented and can your
current security controls that you have
put in place identify detect and prevent
these attacks from happening in the
first place and that is what ethical
hacking is all about
let's look at the Metasploit attack
Metasploit is a framework of penetration
testing that makes hacking very simple
you just need to know how to utilize the
tool you need to identify the
vulnerability associated with a
particular exploit and then run the
exploit on Metasploit uh we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits inactive exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a lesson
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at the end we would then try
to connect and exploit that particular
vulnerability this is the Practical that
we'll be doing on Metasploit so let's
move on with the demos and then we'll
see what we can discuss amongst them all
right let's have a look at some of the
demos that we had talked about in the
ethical hacking and penetration testing
module we are going to look at three
different demos the first one is going
to be a SQL injection attack that we are
going to perform on this tool that we
have the second one is a password
cracking attack on Windows 7 and the
third one is uh Meetup reader based or a
Metasploit based shell shock attack on a
Linux based web server so let's get
cracking I've powered on this virtual
machine which is the ovas broken web
application it is a tool that is
provided for people who want to enhance
their skills and they can practice how
to do these attacks in a legal manner so
we are going to go to this site I'm just
going to open up my browser the IP
address is 71.132 and that's the ovas
broken web application that we want to
utilize we're going to head off to
mutility2 and we are going to look at a
SQL injection attack where we want to
bypass Authentication now this takes us
to the login screen so we can just try
our luck here and see that the
authentication mechanism works the
account does not exist so the username
and password that you have supplied is
not the correct one so we want to ensure
that there's a SQL database and we can
try to attack it and see if we can
bypass the authentication now what we
want to do is we want to create a SQL
based malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's an error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
gave us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how this syntax worked here
we're just going to see if we can create
a malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is
create the query over here I'm going to
give it a comparison so we're going to
give it a r 1 equals 1 space hyphen
hyphen space and if you now click login
you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database an Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query work wonders where it allowed
us to bypass authentication so it also
depends on what kind of a page I am and
what query would be accepted at this
point point in time so your application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we are
calling upon when we are connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single code or and
give it a condition single quote or one
equals one space hyphenation space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the SQL
injection attack that we wanted to look
at let's move on to password tracking
now this is a Windows 7 machine that we
have I'm just going to do a very basic
password tracking example we're just
going to log okay now here the
assumption is that we are able to log in
we have access to a computer and we want
to check out other users who are using
this computer and see if we can find out
their passwords so that we can log in as
a different user steal data if required
and we wouldn't be to blame if there are
any logs that are created so here we've
got a tool called K N able that is
installed right here now I'm already an
administrator on this machine and
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password I can crack and thus I would be
able to get access through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so this allows me to go into a cracker
tool and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so I'm just
going to click on the plus sign and I'm
going to import hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does Windows store its passwords
in what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users or hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example a dictionary based attack or
a Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so we
are going to try to create an ntlm hash
attack and here we are going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and lowercase A through Z uppercase A
through Z numeric zero through nine and
all the special characters let's say the
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that you
want to try the Brute Force attack on
what is a group Force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100 successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a
Kali Linux machine to hack that device
and I'm going to just power off my
Windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pen testers
lab and has a shell shock vulnerability
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability affects Linux Mac and Unix
based operating systems for a particular
version of The Bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we are going to use the Kali Linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use Metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the IP
address we have no idea what the IP
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called Zen map I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my purpose is this
with a subnet mask of
255255255.0 so I want to see if there
are any other machines that are live in
the same subnet and we are doing a ping
swipe over here to identify which
machines are live in a minute we'll get
all the IP addresses 71.1 to 133 254 and
128 we know that VR 128 at this point in
time uh 254 is the DHCP server so we are
assuming that 133 is the machine that we
want to look at and let's then try to
see if we can scan that machine why 133
and we're going to do an intense scan to
find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pen test machine that
we were looking for you can see of the
start Port 22 and Port 80 and somewhere
here it's going to give us the ports
that are open and the details about
those ports and somewhere here it will
tell us that this is the pen tester lab
machine that we wanted which is correct
so now we want to do a vulnerability
analysis on this what we are going to do
is I'm going to use another GUI based
tool called Sparta which I can just find
out from here Sparta uses two tools in
the background nmap tool and a tool
called Necto so we're just going to
start scanning 192 168 71.1 33 was the
IP address add to scope and over a
period of time you can see all of these
will start populating with information
the VR that's the nickto tool coming in
scanning on Port 80 which is uh which
means that it's a web server using HTTP
it tells us it's an Apache HD httpd
2.2.21 and gives us the 22 port number
as well if we head over to the tab of
nickto or let's look at the screenshot
first this is what the website will be
looking like and Necto gives us the
options over here it tells us that there
is a vulnerability over here for shell
shock and this is the path where the
vulnerability is going to exist so what
we are going to do we go back to the
command line sorry we open up a new one
minimize all these other windows and
you're going to open up Metasploit
Metasploit is a penetration testing tool
that is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1700
exploits right here we're going to see
all those exploits with these commands
that we are sorry for the typo and it
will just give us a list of all the
exploits that are stored in Metasploit
in this version so all of these are
windows based if we scroll up we will be
looking at other availabilities as well
our exploits the unique space exploits
linax OS X multi-exploits and we are
looking for a exploit for a multi-based
Apache or HTTP let's go up uh let's look
at so this is the one that we're looking
for Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victims machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin slash status enter
now with exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and will give us a list of all
the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection which is this so we know
it's a Linux operating system we want
this payload to be set so set payload
press enter that's the payload coming in
show options now that you have set the
payload this is the options for the
exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCB connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
localhost or lhost
192.168
71.128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack I can see that it
has created a meter Builder session at
the victim side and it has opened up a
session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connect it to where
www.cgi hyphen Wim do an LS it will list
all the files that's the status file
over there do a CD backslash it will
take us to the root of this machine now
remember we saw the passwords on a
Windows machine similarly we can head
over to the cdetc folder LS and you can
see these files psswd and Shadow now
psswd is the file where Linux Stores its
usernames and Shadow is the file where
passwords are shown so do a cat command
psswd and you can see these users coming
up so you can see the last user pen test
lab and you can see there are no
passwords so let's do a cat Shadow and
that's your hash value for the password
that we have for the user print test lab
so these are the different attacks that
we need to understand uh and we need to
create based on the vulnerabilities that
exist on different machines so if you
just looked at windows and Linux and how
we can explain them depending on
existing vulnerabilities as a ethical
hacker this is uh what we need to learn
in our trainings and then we need to
clear our exams based on this knowledge
of how these things work so that we get
certified and then we can position
ourselves for the penetration testing
jobs if you're interested in pursuing a
career in cyber security and acquiring
the necessary skills then our
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with the MIT University
is surely the right option for you so
hurry up and find the course link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details
Kali Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
Kali Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Kali
Linux takes its roots from the Debian
operating system Debian has been a
highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of Kali become disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a deeper
element of control to the most
enthusiastic of users
we did not get Kali Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its history
Linux is based on years of knowledge and
experience in building penetration
testing and operating systems during all
these project lifelines there have been
only a few different developers as the
team has always been small the first
project was called wapix which stands
for white hat knopex as can be inferred
from the name it was based on the nopex
operating system as its underlying OS
Optics had releases ranging from version
2.0 to 2.7
this made way for the next project which
was known as wax or the long hand being
white hat slacks the name change was
because the base OS was changed from
nopics to slacks wax started at version
3 as a Nord at carrying on from mop X
there was a similar OS being produced at
the same time auditor security
collection often being shorted to just
auditor which was once again using
nopics
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack
backtrack was based on slackware from
version 1 to version 3 but switched to
Ubuntu later on with version 4 to
version 5. using the experience gained
from all of this Kal Linux came after
backtrack in 2013. Kali started off
using Debian stable as the engine under
the hood before moving to Debian testing
when Kali Linux became a rolling
operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of Kali Linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct features
the latest version of Kali comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either similar did
not work which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality
the Kali Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external asset greatly
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cybercrime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in general
since Arm based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Linux is available on a wide range of
arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainland
distributions so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
all this information is necessary for
users to determine if Kali Linux is the
correct choice for them
if it is what are the ways that they can
go forward with this installation and
start their penetration testing Journey
the first way to use Kali Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB
some people don't need to save their
data permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the caviar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USPS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations
but what if the user wants to store data
permanently in the installed OS the best
and the most reliable way to ensure this
is the full-fledged hard disk
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of Linux
the next alternative route for
installing Kali Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtualbox the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and Kali Linux
can be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window
the hardware requirements will be
completely customizable starting with
the allotted Ram to the virtual hard
disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like car Linux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting the systems at risk if you
want to learn more about how one can go
forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where Kali Linux is
being installed on VMware while running
on a Windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine
the final way to install Kali Linux is
by using a dual boot system to put it in
simple words the Kali Linux OS will not
be overriding any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and Kali Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system
professionals and security testing
penetration testing and ethical hacking
utilize Linux as their preferred
operating system
provides several configurable
distributions that mu May configure
based on your end use color Linux and
parrot os are two popular penetration
testing distributions
while these operating systems each have
unique offerings the overall Choice can
differ between Personnel thanks to the
various tools and Hardware
specifications
today we will look at both these
distributions and settle on the perfect
choice for each type of user
let's go to the agenda for this video
we will learn about Kali Linux and pilot
security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers
next we know about some features of
these operating systems that stand out
of their package
finally we directly compare Carl Linux
and pirate security OS thereby making a
clear-cut conclusion on which OS is
perfect on a per requirement basis
so let's start by learning about Carl
Linux from a ground level
Kal Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools
targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
College Linux is a multi-platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Colin
Linux takes its rules from the Debian
operating system
Debian has been a highly dependable and
a stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the Kali Linux desktop
while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of college Linux come
disabled by default
this is done to prevent any external
factors from affecting the installation
procedure which may pose a risk in
critical environments
apart from boosting security it allows a
more profound element of security
control to the most enthusiastic of
users
now let's take a look at parent security
operating system
parent security OS is a Debian based
trademarks distribution with an emphasis
on security privacy and development
it is built on the Damian's testing
branch and uses a custom hardened Linux
kernel
parrot security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards tasks such as
penetration testing computer forensics
reverse engineering and security
research it is seen as a generally
lightweight distribution that can work
under rigorous hardware and software
specifications
it features a distinct forensics mode
that does not Mount any of the system's
hard disks or partitions and has no
influence on the host system making it
much more stealthy than its regular
occurrence this mode is used on the host
system to execute forensic procedures
a rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions in software development this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date a rolling release
distribution such as parrot security OS
follows the same concept
it provides the most recent Linux kernel
and software versions as soon as they
become available
with the basic introduction to the
operating systems out of the way let us
take a look at the unique features of
both Kali Linux and parrot security OS
the latest version of Kali Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar functionality
the Kali Linux team comprises a small
group of individuals who are the only
ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets dramatically
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cyber crime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a strong
hold over the configuration and the
device in general
since arm-based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of ERM devices and has ERM repositories
integrated with the mainline
distribution so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
let's take a look at some of the
features of parrot security operating
system now
along with a giant catalog of scripts
parent security OS has its own Hardware
Linux kernel modified explicitly to
provide as much security and resistance
to hackers as possible in the first line
of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as the second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latex Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parrot OS
development team will most likely iron
it out first before passing it on as an
update
foreign
kernel was increasing enough parent
security developers managed to install
more hacking tools and scripts to ensure
a smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure
and this has been achieved while keeping
roughly the same operating system size
between both of them
however it's not all productivity points
for parrot OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments made which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a
distribution
being highly modular in nature one can
use parent security OS while adding
another desktop environment that they
find appealing while car Learners has
only a single option parent security has
provided two optimized bills with made
desktop and KDE desktop
one of the primary advantages of parrot
OS over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality Paradise is
designed to operate successfully of a
USB stick but Kali Linux does not work
well from a USB drive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine
parrot OS is more of a niche
distribution if you're searching for
something lighter than colors
features are great but what about
Performance Real World metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability
in the end we can decide on what
distribution is fit for each type of
user
for a first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ram required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature Prime usage is a very
important facet while College Linux
demands at least 1GB of ram parallel
security can operate optimally with a
minimum of 320 MB of RAM
thank you
for correctly displaying graphical
elements Kali Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parrot security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos
they take up a minimum amount of
Hardware storage both of these operating
systems have a recommended disk storage
of minimum of 20 GB in Kali Linux and a
minimum of 15 GB in parrot security so
they can install all the tools necessary
in the ISO file
when it comes to the category and the
selection of tools Carl Linux has always
been the first in securing every single
tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a notch
while specializing in Wireless pen
testing parrot security makes it a point
that all the tools that kalu Linux
provides has been included in the iso
while simultaneously adding some extra
tools that many users will have to
install from third party sources in Kali
Linux
being a decade old penetration testing
distribution Kali Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature parrot Security on the other
hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of Kali Linux is the
extensive Hardware requirement
to perform optimally it requires higher
memory than pilot security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard disk storage parrot
Security on the other hand was initially
designed to run off a USB drive directly
thereby requiring very minimal
requirements from a hardware perspective
like just 320 MB of RAM and no graphical
acceleration needed this means parrot
security is much more feasible for
people who are not able to devote
massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered to
one can go with color Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years
if they have a powerful system which can
run Kali Linux optimally without having
to bottleneck performance
and if they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners
one can decide to go with parrot
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight ending distribution that can
run pretty much on all systems
it also has a lot of tools pre-installed
and some of them are not even present on
car Linux
it is much more suitable for
underpowered rigs where users do not
have a lot of Hardware resources to
provide to the operating system and
thereby it is much more feasible for
people with underpowered laptops or no
graphical acceleration
compared to Kali Linux parrot Securities
desktop environment is also relatively
easier to use for new beginners for
people who are just getting into ethical
hacking parent security does a
relatively better job
of introducing them to the operating
system and the various tools without
having to dump them into the entire
intricacies the installation of Kali
Linux there are multiple ways to install
Kali Linux we can either install it on a
normal hard drive in a virtual machine
software such as VMware or virtualbox or
we can do that in hard bare metal
machines now for the convenience of
explanation we're going to install Kali
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware
VMware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a Windows 10 system
to get started with Kali Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image file
we go to get Kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted as per our requirement
we're going to go with the virtual
machine section as you can see it is
already recommended by the Developers
this is the download button which will
download a 64-bit ISO file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a window archive
which will have the ISO files
for now we have downloaded the ISO file
and it is already present with me so we
can start working on the VMS side of
things
once the ISO file is downloaded we open
up VMware Workstation
go to file
and we create a new virtual machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the custom one the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but from 90 of the cases
typical setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be I will install the
operating system later
and some operating systems we can use
the ISO file here directly and VMware
will install it for us but for right now
in the case of Kali Linux the third
option is always the safest
color Linux is a Linux distribution so
we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here we have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels
every distribution has of a parent
distribution for example Kali Linux has
Debian and there are other distributions
which are based or forked from some
parent distribution colleges is based
off Debian so we can go with the highest
version of Debian which is the Debian
10.x 64-bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write Kali Linux so that it will be
easier to recognize the virtual machine
among this list of virtual machine
instances the location can be any
location you decide to put by default it
should be the documents folder but
anywhere you put it will hold up all the
information of the operating system all
the files you download all the
configurations you store everything will
be stored in this particular location
that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of Cal Linux think of
your Windows device if you have a one
terabyte of hard drive you have the
entirety of the hard disk to store data
on how much data you give here you can
only store up to that amount of data not
to mention some amount of capacity will
be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
GB of information or if a recommended
size for typing is 20 you can just go
ahead at 20 it depends all on the user
case if you are going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual disks as a single file
or storing them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files now even if this
makes a reporting virtual machines
easier from either system to system or
software to software let's say if you
want to switch from VMware to virtualbox
or vice versa the performance takes a
small hit it's not huge but it's
recommended to go with storing the
virtual disk as a single file if you
have no purposes of ever moving the
virtual machine even if you do it's not
a complete stop that it cannot be ported
it's just easier when using multiple
files but in order to get the best
performance out of the virtual machine
we can store it as a single file over
here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now now at
this point of time we have not provided
the dot ISO file yet which is the
installation file for the Kali Linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have color Linux in the list now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
the devices with ram of 8 GB odds below
that giving high amount of ram will
cause performance issues and the host
system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6 GB it will
be much more difficult for the host
system to run everything properly so for
this instance we can keep it as 2GB of
memory for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if you
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the SCSI hard
disk and it does not need to be changed
for the installation of this operating
system at all
cdid DVD this is where the installation
file comes you can think of the ISO file
that we downloaded as a pen drive or a
USB thumb drive which is necessary to
install an operating system to provide
this
we're going to select use ISO image file
we're going to click on browse
go on go to downloads and select the Im
so file over here
select open
and we can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use Nat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or Lan segments but those are
not necessary for installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press OK and now we can power on this
virtual machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
you're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with English as
standard
this is a location this should be used
for setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location of the user so for this
we're going to go with India
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the American
English first many people make a mistake
of going with the Indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always prefer to
go with the American English and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect adaptiveness required
we can install it later but for now we
should always stick with American
English as a basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a hostname for the system
this hostname can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name Kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next you're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its use root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one two three
foreign now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here there are multiple options
like the use entire disk use entire disk
instead of lvm use entire disk instead
of encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
we can learn afterwards when you are
much more Hands-On with the Linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
VMware we had set up a disk capacity
there we gave our preposter 20 GB that
is the hardness which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual disk on VMware it acts as a
normal hard disk on which an operating
system can be installed so we select
this one and press on continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the RAM management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of one GB
used for swap memory now these kind of
naming can be confusing for people who
are not well versed with Linux operating
systems or in general virtualization but
for now you can go ahead and press on
continue as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it so that SCSI 3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20 GPS disk capacity
we write the changes to the disk we
press yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the num amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2GB of RAM we're going
to speed up this part of the video so we
don't have to waste any more time just
watching the progress bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for Google Chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time is ask us to
select our Network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
it's going to ask us for an HTTP proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the Kali Linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
Kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it has installed the grub
bootloader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev SDA
so we're going to select installation of
the Guard loader on the same hard disk
that we have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from even if
the operating system is installed
correctly and all the files are in
correct order the absence of a
bootloader will not be able to launch
the OS properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
now you can see Carl Linux being booted
up straight away it doesn't check for
the ISO file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the calendar system booted
up
and this is your home page
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
Carl Linux and others can be installed
using the APT package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
Kali Linux is complete it's no secret
that the vast bulk of our internet usage
is vulnerable to hacking whether it's so
hazardous messaging apps or faulty
operating systems
penetration testing has become the norm
for vulnerability assessment in order to
fill this vacuum in digital security
Kali Linux is a well-known operating
system in this fight against hackers
Kali Linux a distribution designed
specifically for penetration testers has
layers of features that we will go over
in today's lesson and take a look at
some of the tools and features that the
operating system has to offer
let's take a look at their videos topics
and features that the operating system
has to offer
let's take a look at their videos topics
we start by learning the requirements of
an operating system like Carly Linux
we learn more about the core features of
the OS and its intricacies
moving on we take a look at the five
distinct stages of penetration testing
they dictate the flow of vulnerability
assessment in general
next we learn about some important tools
that can be found on Kali Linux which
are geared specifically for ethical
hacking purposes
and finally we have an extensive
demonstration where we work on some
basic terminal commands proxy tools and
a couple of Highly regarded software
from the Crux of the operating system
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
let's start by learning why one should
learn Kali Linux in the first place
in today's world in organization's most
valuable asset is its information or
data this is true for all kinds of
businesses be it public or private on a
daily basis they all deal with enormous
amounts of sensitive information
as a consequence terrorist groups
hacking teams and cyber thieves often
attack them to ensure the safety and
protection businesses use a variety of
security measures and regularly update
their index
organizations must be proactive in this
age of digitalization by regularly
assessing and updating their security
every day hackers discover new methods
to breach firewalls ethical hackers or
white hat hackers provide a fresh
perspective on security they conduct
penetration test to validate security
measures generally they will penetrate
your networks and give you relevant
information about your security posture
once an organization has this knowledge
it may upgrade its security procedures
accordingly
the latest version of Kali Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed
after reviewing every tool that was
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a great number of tools that
either simply did not work
or which duplicated other tools that
provided the same or similar
functionality
occasionally when conducting penetration
testing or hacking we must automate our
activities since there may be hundreds
of conditions and payloads to test and
manually examining everything is time
consuming
to improve our productivity we utilize
tools that come pre-packaged with Carly
Linux these tools not only save us time
but also accurately capture and process
the data
the Kylie Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets greatly
reduces the risk of source contamination
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need to do for the
job
since Arm based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainline
distribution so tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution tools
now that we understand the necessity for
an operating system like car Linux let
us take a look at some of its core
features and offerings to the ethical
hacking world
Kali Linux formerly known as backtrack
Linux is an open source Linux
distribution which is aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering
Kali Linux is a multi-platform solution
accessible and freely available to
Information Security Professionals and
hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Kali
Linux takes its route from the Debian
operating system
Debian has been a highly dependable and
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the Kali Linux desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of color Linux come disabled
by default
this is done to prevent any external
factors from affecting the installation
procedure which may pose a risk in
critical environments apart from
boosting security that allows a deeper
element of security and control to the
most enthusiastic of users
let us now take a look at the five
stages or phases of penetration testing
this is the first stage of the
penetration test which is known as the
reconnaissance phase
in this stage the security researcher
collects information about the target it
can be done actively which means you are
collecting information without
contacting the Target or even both
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
Network components active machines open
ports and access points operating system
details Etc
this activity can be performed by using
information available in the public
domain and using different tools
the next phase is more tool oriented
rather than perform manually and it is
the scanning phase
the penetration tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the target the penetration tester
runs one or more scanner tools to gather
information about the target
by using various scanners such as war
dialers port scanners Network mappers
and vulnerability scanners the tester
collects as many vulnerabilities which
help to turn an attack in a more
sophisticated way
the next stage is known as the gaining
access phase
in this phase the penetration tester
tries to establish a connection with the
Target and exploit the vulnerabilities
found in the previous stage
exploitation may be buffer overflow
attacks denial of service or dos attacks
session hijacking and many more
basically penetration tester extracts
information and sensitive data from
servers by gaining access using
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
backdoor for himself
it helps him to identify hidden
vulnerabilities in the system and can
later act as a gateway to retrieve
control of the system
in the Final Phase of covering tracks
the penetration tester tries to remove
all logs and Footprints which help the
administrator identify his presence this
helps the tester to think like a hacker
and perform corrective actions to
mitigate those activities
now that we understand the basics of
penetration testing and how ethical
hackers go about the way let us take a
look at some notable tools which can be
used on Kali Linux
at the top of the chain lies nmap
nmap is a free and open source utility
Port scanner which can be used for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking that a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hacker to
leverage any insecure openings and
breach the device
it's a part of the scanning phase of the
penetration testing
nmap uses raw IP packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what services these hosts
are offering what operating systems they
are running and their versions what type
of packet filters and firewalls are in
use and dozens of other characteristics
it was designed to rapidly scan large
networks but works fine against single
hosts as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
Rockport or server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on the list we have Metasploit
the Metasploit framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe systemic vulnerabilities on
networks and servers as a part of the
third stage of penetration testing it's
an open source framework which can be
easily customized and used with most
operating systems
with Metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use a ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots as another flavor of threat
hunting once these flaws are identified
and documented the information can be
used to address systemic weaknesses and
prioritize Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the exploit is fed into
the system there are a host of options
for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all
personal data stored on the device
a big advantage of Metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on a
Target system thereby giving a detailed
picture of the security index of said
system
this also provides the necessary
exploits that can be used to bypass the
firewalls and the anti-virus software
having a single solution to gather
almost all the necessary points of
attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by the high rank in this list
at number 3 we have Wireshark
Wireshark is the world's foremost and
widely used networking protocol analyzer
it lets you see what happening on your
network at a microscopic level and is
the de facto standard across many
commercial and non-profit Enterprises
government agencies and educational
institutions
Wireshark is a popular open source tool
to capture Network packets and converts
them to human readable binary format it
provides every single detail of the
organization's Network infrastructure it
consists of devices designed to help
measure the ins and outs of the network
The information collected to Wireshark
can be used for various purposes such as
real-time or offline network analysis
identification of the traffic coming
onto your network its frequency and its
latency between specific hops this helps
Network administrators generate
statistics based on real-time data
Wireshark is also a cross-platform tool
that can be installed on Windows Linux
and Mac systems to enable hackers in all
ecosystems to monitor Network traffic
irrespective of the operating system
the development team is determined to
maintain this level of freedom for their
users in the foreseeable future
the next tool on our list is air Garden
which is a part of the third phase of
penetration testing
this is a multi-use bash script for
Linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday Wi-Fi router
and its counterparts
along with being able to launch denial
of service attacks on compromise
networks this multipurpose wi-fi hacking
tool has very rich features which
support multiple methods for wi-fi
hacking including multiply WPS hacking
modes all in one WEP attack handshake
file capturing evil twin attacks pixie
dust and so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
Wireless traffic traversing the air
channels
thanks to its open source nature air
Garden can be used with multiple
Community plugins and add-ons thereby
increasing its Effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz band and 5 gigahertz band
the next tool is John the Ripper
John the Ripper is an open source
password security auditing and password
recovery tool available for many
operating systems
John the Ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and Cipher types including for
user passwords of operating systems web
apps groupware database servers
Network traffic captures encrypted
private Keys file systems and document
files some of the key features of the
tool include offering multiple modes to
speed up password tracking automatically
detecting the hashing algorithm used by
the passwords and the ease of running
and configuring the tool making it a
password cracking script of choice for
novices and professionals alike
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word list being used in this
dictionary attacks can be used from the
user's end allowing for a completely
customizable process
now that we have covered the basics of
Kali Linux let us take a look at the
agenda for our demo today
we start out with a few terminal
commands that are a basic part of a
Linux operating system
configure our own proxy chains to
maintain anonymity while running
penetration testing attacks on our
victims
next we run a few nmap scans on a local
Windows 10 machine to find out the type
of information that can be gathered in
such a scenario
moving on we use Wireshark to monitor
internet traffic and understand the
importance of encryption and security
when browsing the World Wide Web
next we learn about Metasploit and its
various applications in the line of
vulnerability assessment of a device
and finally we use mattress provide to
take root access of a fully updated
Windows 10 computer system
let's begin with some terminal Basics on
Kali Linux
when most people hear the term Linux
they Envision a complex operating system
used only by programmers however the
experience is not as frightening as it
appears Linux is an umbrella term for a
collection of free and open source Unix
operating systems there are many
variants like Ubuntu Fedora Debian these
are distributions which will be a more
precise term when using a Linux
operating system you will most likely
utilize a shell which is a command line
interface that provides access to the
operating system Services the majority
of Linux distributions ship with a
graphical user interface also known as
GUI as their primary shell this is done
to facilitate user interaction in the
first place having said that a command
line interface is suggested due to its
increased power and Effectiveness by
entering the commands into the CLI tasks
that require a multi-step GUI procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
you can start the terminal by clicking
on the prompt icon here on top
once the terminal is open
we can put up a commands the First
Command that we are going to look into
is PWD PWD stands for present working
directory
as of right now what you are seeing is
the terminal window by default if I
write PWD and press enter this shows the
directory in which the terminal is being
run on as of right now it's in the NF
folder of my desktop which is
specifically this folder if I open up
this folder you can see it is currently
empty as in it has no contents
if I use another command known as mkdir
which is supposed to stand for make
directory and I write an F2 shortage for
new folder 2.
if I open up the NF you can see the new
folder is created this is how the PWD
command works
another important command
to change directories it's called the CD
command let's say right now if I am in
NF I want to create a new file in nf2
folder or something else in the nf2
folder I have to shift to CD and F2
now if I write PWD
it will show the present working
directory of Home simply learn desktop
NF and inside that I am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate through the Linux
files and disk directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this
for now CD Works another few commands is
we can write CD dot dot and it will come
back one folder now the PWD will be just
NF and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go a different file let's say if
we just go for CD
home
simpler
that's it
right now these are the folders in our
current present working directory
we have the desktop the documents
downloads Etc
from here we can again go to the desktop
using the same CD command
cross check the changing of directories
and check the files again and yes there
we go NF how do we know this what are
the command that we are used to show the
files and folders that folder is known
as the ls command LS can be used to view
the contents of a directory by default
this command will display the contents
of your current working directory if we
add some other parameters we can find
the contents of other directories as
well
there are some hidden files as well in
Linux which cannot be showed just with
ls for example if we just go to cdetc
which is a configuration folder for
Linux if we write LS now these are the
files that can be seen
if we want to see the hidden files we'll
have to add one more parameter here like
LS minus a and as you can see the number
of files have increased this time around
there are other things as well that we
can see with Linux
LS minus a l will show the hidden files
along with some of the parameters and
some of the permissions that has been
provided for each file
as you can see many of these files have
root access some of them can write some
of them can read
it differs file to file and the ls minus
Al command is used to check each of
these files permission and change them
accordingly if needed
the next command that we can look for is
the cat command or concatenate
it is one of the most frequently used
commands and it is used to list the
contents of a file on the output
for example let's say if I have a file
at the desktop
in this nf2 folder I will create a
document
create an empty file
e file
I'll open up the document and I'll write
it as
hello Kali
I will save this up
now to change the directories from Etc
to nf2 we have already discussed how to
use the CD command using just the folder
name now if you want to go through the
entire directory we can write Siri
home
as you can see it is already prompting
us to complete the name of the directory
at this point we just have to press tab
and it completes it for ourself next we
already know we have to enter the
desktop
NF and nf2
and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press LS we
can find a file over here now as
discussed with the concatenate it is
used to show the contents of a file so
right now if we press cat which stands
for concatenate
e file
as you can see we have written hello
Kali in the text file and we can see the
output right now
we can also use it to create new files
for example if we write cat
any file name such as e-file 2.
here we can write anything
hello Kali again
once you press Ctrl C here we can check
e File 2 and we have hello Kali again
printed over here we can see the same
using the concatenate command as well if
I press LS you can see we have two files
here and I can go with cat e file to and
I have Hello Kali again this is how the
concatenate command works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
CP which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mindful this is not
moving this is only going to copy the
command for example currently rpwd which
is the present directory is in
the nf2 folder as you can see over here
let's copy the E file to to the NF
folder
we can write CP
e file to
and give the path of the NF folder which
will be home
simply learn
Tech stock
and an F
now if I press LS I'll find both the
files and nf2 since I copied
to go back to the NF folder again we can
again use the same command of
no we can again use the home
simply learn
desktop
and just an F no nf2 this time just
enough
as you can see this will change back our
present working directory now when we
press LS we will find the e-file to file
and the nf2 folder and we can confirm
this using the GUI as well
this is the NF folder and you can see
the nf2 folder and the e-file to
document if I write cat e file to
cat e file to
we can see the contents of the file now
this can be done using moving as well
for example if I go to CD nf2 which is
the inside folder it has both the
document files like e file and e-file 2.
let's say I want to move the e-file
completely from nf2 to NF1 instead of
writing CP the command I am going to use
is MV MV e file and again give the path
of the folder into which I have to copy
which will be again home
simply learn
desktop
and NF
as you can see the contents of the nf2
have appeared here and E file has been
moved from nf2 to
NF
this is this nf2 and we don't find e
file here anymore if we press CD dot dot
and we go back to NF LS right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and E file to that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple one line
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using GUI this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for Linux
operating systems
another very important command for Linux
operating system is the sudo command
Sudo is short for super user do the
command enables you to perform tasks
that require administrative or root
permissions you can think of it as how
we run programs administrator on Windows
systems it is not advisable to use this
cupboard for daily use because it might
be easy for an error to occur and the
permissions of root are very intricate
so new beginners are advised to use the
sudo command only when absolutely
necessary for example
sudo SU
with this command I am giving this
terminal
a root permission
this Su stands for this user
at this point it's going to ask for my
admin password
once I enter my password
and I now have root access note how the
password that I entered did not show up
here this is a security measure to
prevent people from snooping on your
root password which is the end game of
all this operating system
as you also can see the symbol changed
if the dollar symbol is showing its
source as a standard user when you
switch to root you can easily see a hash
symbol
this opens up a separate shell inside
this terminal command for example we can
exit out of the root user to the
standard user using the command exit and
once again we have the dollar sign and
the root has vanished over here there
are some commands that will only work
with administrative access for example
when updating the Kalil Linux system we
have to use apt update
as you can see it says problem unlinking
the file because permission denied now
let's try this using sudo
sudo APD update
as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the system
this can be done using either writing
the sudo command every time we want to
perform a root access or we can just
write sudo Su once and write apt update
alone
the fetching is complete over here
for the second example let's say I just
write sudo Su and this time is not going
to ask me the password because at this
current terminal process I've already
provided the root password once and it
is in memory right now now when we used
to update the system we had to write
sudo apt update that was because we were
running it as a standard user now we are
running it as a root user so all we have
to write is if it update and it's going
to continue its work
there you go
another command that can be useful is
the Ping command it's pretty
self-explanatory it's going to be
checking the internet connectivity you
can be used to check internet
connectivity or you can see if there is
a local server on your system which
needs to be ping then you can check
there for example if we have to write
ping and we can use either IP address or
domain let's say if you want to check
that if we can access google.com using
this Kali Linux installation or not we
can write ping google.com
and you can see it shows the bytes being
sent and received and how much time it
took to take up the request
this can be done for local systems as
well for example this installation of
Kali Linux is being run on a virtual
machine
once this machine is running I still
have my host machine running over here
the IP address of which is
192.168.29 179
if I try to Ping this from here
as you can see the time to complete the
request is drastically low compared to a
website on the internet considering this
is on the local network
this is how the pink command is worked
and it can show you what kind of
packages are transmitted how many are
received if there was any kind of packet
loss between the connection window and
other details
a very important command when working
with the terminal for long duration is a
history command
pretty self-explanatory there are so
many commands that are being run
sometimes people forget what was the
change they did oh what was the
directory name they put a history
command helps to recover some of the
commands that we have written it doesn't
go all the way back but it takes up many
commands that were inputted in the last
few processes
this is how the history command works
these are some of the most commonly used
terminal commands if you want to learn
more about this terminal and every other
feature of this please let us know in
the comment section and we will try to
make an in-depth tutorial especially if
you could
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on Linux
moving on we learn how to configure
proxy chains on a system
proxying refers to the technique of
bouncing your internet traffic through
multiple machines to hide the identity
of the original machine it is a good
tool that hackers use to accomplish this
call is proxy chains
essentially you can use proxy chains to
run any program through a proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your IP address
even allows you to use multiple proxies
At Once by chaining them together
one of the most important reasons that
proxy chains is used in a security
context is that it's easy to evade
detection attackers often use proxies to
hide their true identities while
executing an attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located
to see how proxygen works let's open
Firefox first and check our current IP
address
write Firefox
and there we go
as we can see Firefox is now open
let's check our current IP address right
now
if we go to an address called my ip.com
and you can see it easily detects our
country is in India and this is a public
IP address
now if we move to the terminal again
here we can now write
proxy chains
minus h
what is minus H does is it finds a help
it it stands for the help file this is
for help file
what we found out using this is proxy
chains has a config file here
Etc proxychains4 dot comf this is the
config file found using this config file
we can customize how our proxy change
should work
if we want to open that we have to use
it in a text editor on Windows we have
notepad and other things like that
Microsoft Word to edit documents on
Linux we have a tool called Nano to
access the Nano we use the command Nano
and give the path of the file that we
want to check as of right now the proxy
chance config file is located over here
so we're going to follow the path there
chains 4 Dot comf
and here we go we see the config file
there are three basic types of proxy
chaining here
we have a strict chain where all the
proxy in the list
will be used and they will be changed in
order
we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy genes will
be done by a random combo proxies in the
proxy list
when you have a dynamic chain it's the
same as strict chain but dead proxies
are excluded from the chain
and here we can set up whichever type we
want
to enable or disable a particular type
we use the hash symbol here as you can
see right now all the lines have a
hashtag symbol at the front except this
one a dynamic chain this is the current
one being used let's say if I want to
use a strict chain method so I can add a
hash value here
and remove the hash here at one point of
time any one of these three four types
should be enabled
let's go for the Dynam Dynamic chain
we can disable this strict Chain by
putting the hashtag in front
and removing the dynamic chain
as you can see below we have few
commands to how to handle the Nano text
editor this symbol is known as the
control button on your keyboard now if
we want to write out which is synonymous
to saving the file
supposed to go with Ctrl O So if I press
Ctrl o on my keyboard it says file name
to write and we have to press enter here
since we want to overwrite the proxy
chains 4 dot comf file we don't want to
create a new file over here so just
press enter
and we get a permission to write this
permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this using a
standard user Etc is a system folder to
be able to use make some changes we have
to use it using a sudo command
to exit this Nano we have to use the
control X command we use Ctrl X
we're going to clear
and this time we're going to use the
sudo command
sudo Nano
Etc
proxy chains
4.0
and we have the same file open up again
now this time if you want to make a
change let's say we're going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from strict
we're going to use Ctrl o for the save
file option we're going to press enter
and it says root 160 lines
again if you want to reverse this change
we put the hashtag over here
enable Dynamic chain
we press Ctrl o
press enter and it says root 160 lines
now we can exit straight away using the
control X format
right now we have not provided any file
or a proxy chain we can have proxy IP
addresses from the internet but we have
to make sure that they are safe and they
don't Snoop on our data
when there is no proxy chains being
provided personally it going it's going
to use the Tor Network but for that we
have to start door
is a service in Linux to know more about
the store we can write sudo systemctl
which is used to know the status of
services on the Linux operating system
and status of torque
a system CTL sorry uh as instead of STL
it should be system CTL status Tor as
you can see it is a toss service
anonymizing overlay Network for TCP
connections and it's currently inactive
now to start this up we have to write
sudo system CTL start
Dot now if we repeat the same sudo
system CTL status Star as you can see
it's active now
you can see the green logo over here
okay
to integrate the Firefox and the browser
we can use the proxy chains command
directly over here we can write proxy
chains we can use Firefox to launch our
web browser and let's say if we want to
visit google.com
we press enter
and the Firefox window is launched
and it should open a google.com next
and there we go
if we go to my ip.com once again
as you can see we have a different IP
address and the country is a known as
well
so this is how we can use proxy chains
to anonymize our internet usage when
using Kali Linux
next on our agenda is the ability to
scan networks using nmap
at its core nmap is a network scanning
tool that uses IP packets to identify
all the devices connected to a network
can learn more about nmap using their
help file
as you can see these are some of the
parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of a system you can see
the version and the URL of the webs of
the service
over here the primary users of nmap can
be broken into three group processors
first the program gives you detailed
information on every IP active on your
network and then each IPA can then be
scanned
secondly it can also be used to
providing a lot of live hosts and open
ports as well as identifying the OS of
every connected device
thirdly
and map has also become a valuable tool
for users looking to protect personal
and business websites
using nmap to scan your own web server
particularly if you are hosting your
website from home is essentially
simulating the process that a hacker
would use to attack your site attacking
your own site in this way is a powerful
way of identifying security
vulnerabilities
as we already discussed The Host Windows
10 machine on the system has an IP
address a 192 168 29.179
if you want to test the OS scan of the
system we're going to first get the root
permission over here
we use the sudo command and now we are a
root user we're going to launch the
command and map
minus o which is supposed to be an OS
detection scan the IP address we can use
of the host system
192.168.29.179
in a legitimate penetration testing
scenario we can use the IP address of
the vulnerable disk device over here
we are going to let it scan for a while
and it's going to give us some guesses
on what can the OS be
as you can see the scan is done and it
has shown some of the ports that are
open
you can see the msrpc port open at the
https 443 Port open which is used to
connect to the internet and it has some
aggressive OS guesses as well for
example it thinks there's a 90 94 chance
that it's going to be a Microsoft
Windows XP Service Pack 3. that's partly
because a lot of the Windows XP update
packages are still prevalent on Windows
now that the OS detection is confirmed
there are multiple more details that we
can gather from nmap
let's go with the NF minus a command
which is supposed to capture as much
data as possible
there is also a speed setting you can
call it a speed setting or a control
setting of the minus t
minus t ranges from t 0 to T1 to T
through all the way up to D5
this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it will take more
time to provide the results but it will
also give a less chance for the
intrusion detection system on the
vulnerable machine firewall to detect
that someone is trying to penetrate the
network for now if we want to go with
somewhat of a high speed we can go with
the T4 and provide the same IP address
of the local machine I am trying to
attack
it's going to take a little bit of time
since it's trying to capture a lot of
information
as you can see the results are now
here
it launched a scan and took a few top
ports that are most likely vulnerable
from a Windows XP perspective and it
showed
a few ports over here it has not shown
991 filtered ports which could not be
attacked anyway since they were closed
for outside access it shows a few
fingerprint settings like the connection
policies and the port details
it shows an HTTP options some other
intricate details that can be used when
you attacking its servers
it shows a VMware version that it's
running
and some few other ports over here
apart from that we also have the
aggressive OS gases over here just like
we did with the minus o and you can see
this time it is showing Windows 7 as 98
percent
no exactos matches since uh if there was
any exactos matches we could have seen a
hundred percent chances over here
this is a trace route a trace route will
be the time and the path a connection
request takes from the source to the
destination for example this request
went from 192
168.72.2 to a destination address since
this is a local machine it took only a
single step and multiple occasions if
you're trying to access a remote system
it's going to be a number of free suits
when it jumps from firewall to firewall
and router to router
this is how we can use nmap to find
information about a system and find some
vulnerable ports we can access
moving on we have a tutorial on how to
use Wireshark to sniff Network traffic
to start using Wireshark we're going to
have to open the application first now
during installation of Wireshark there
is an option to enable if non-root users
can be able to capture traffic or not
in my installation I have disabled that
so I will be launching Wireshark when
using the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
Wi-Fi adapter
you can see it over here in the VM tab
removable devices
our link 802.1 and WLAN
this is a external Wi-Fi adapter which
is inserted into my USB system
you can see it over here if I write
iwconfig
this is the one wlan0 this is absolutely
necessary because we need to have a
monitor mode required we won't need it
for sniffing data on Wireshark right now
but it's going to be necessary later on
in this tutorial as well as we will see
for now we can just start up Wireshark
by writing its name on the command line
and it should start the program
here we go
here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which supposed to
stand for ethernet 0 Port you can see
data is being transmitted up and down
we're going to select eth0
and we have started capturing data you
can see this data request from the
source so destination and the time and
the which protocol it is following
everything we can see and we can see the
ipv4 flags here as well
as you can see over here
to capture internet traffic
we can try running Firefox
if we just write Wikipedia
.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing
okay this is a spelling mistake
Wikipedia
yeah
you can see the application data of all
these requests going up
and they're connected to a destination
server of 1 0 through 102.166.224
now if you even if we check the
transmission control protocol Flags over
here and so many more things we cannot
find anything beneficial as you can see
the information over here is gibberish
which is supposed to be since it's
supposed to be encrypted
now
this is possible due to this being an
https website hence you can see the lock
symbol over here and connection is
supposed to be secure
now what about HTTP ports we have seen
many people recommend to not visit HTTP
ports
repeat
we have seen many people recommend to
not visit HTTP websites and even if we
have to visit to not provide any
critical information
for example let's go to a random
HTTP page over here
as you can see this is
saying connection is not secure and this
is an HTTP HTTP page and not https
now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form let's say I have a
legitimate account over here
if I write my account name
and my password is supposed to be
password one two three four
I press login
and the password does not match because
I do not have an account over here but
let's say I did and I was logged in as
expected you can go to Wireshark we can
use filters over here now all the
requests that I am sending it's a TCP
request so I can write a filter
containing TCP
contains
whatever string if it is being passed
let's say for the end user name I write
my account name
so I can just write my account name over
here
and press enter
to find a request over here now as you
can see
there are many flags over here
if we go to the HTT HTML form URL
encoded and open up some of its Flags
as you can see I can see my account name
and simply learn password over here this
is the same
details that I input on the website
let's say I did have a legitimate
account on this website I would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who will be using Wireshark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here
this is why it's recommended to not
provide any information on HTTP Pages
the security is not up to the mark and
always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or making any
internet transactions or providing any
information
this is how we can use Wireshark to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred to the
network adapter
next we have to learn about what is
Metasploit
the Metasploit project is a computer
security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and AIDS in penetration
testing and IDs development
we can open up the terminal here we're
going to allow root access
and to open up Metasploit the key word
is msf console
that's going to take a little bit of
time to start it up
now the Metasploit console has been
loaded
from here we can decide what type of
attack we want to launch and what kind
of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets for example like we
already discussed I am running this
virtual machine on a Windows 10 host
machine so if I open the command prompt
from my Windows 10 over here
if I need to check the IP address once I
go with ipconfig
here you can see the IP address of this
local machine
moving on
if we have to attack that machine let's
say we want to see what kind of exploits
is going to work over there
now we already know that Windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the HTA server
vulnerability HTA is supposed to be a
HTML application but when past the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system
to start off with the Metasploit and
accessing such applications
we're going to use the command use
exploit and the name of the reverse HTA
server is this windows
for miscellaneous
HDA server
as you can see it already found this one
all right now there are some options
that we need to set for this exploit to
go through for example you can see some
of the options over here there is a
payload the payload is supposed to be
the malicious file that we are going to
send on the HTML application which
allows us to give the back door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a Windows meter
printer reverse TCP
completely understandable now let's set
the L host
L host and R host and SRV host should be
the one where we are going to launch the
attack from for example if we launched
another tab of this console
and we just press i f config
the IP address is 192 plus 168 72 130.
so we're going to set the L host as
192.168.72.130
and we're going to do the same thing
with SRV host
we're going to set up port
where we need to capture the back door
axis
next the payload has already been set
this payload will launch a back door and
give us meter printer access to the
system meterpreter is can be considered
as an upgrade of a normal command prompt
shell we will look into it once we get
the access in the first place
now that we have set the commands we can
press on exploit and press enter
now
you can see we have a URL over here
we're going to copy this URL
once the URL is copied we take it into
the browser and paste it
this will ask us to download this file
now as per browser security settings
this file should be blocked by default
we can decide to keep it and with the
correct formulation of this malicious
package even the website browser
antivirus softwares will not be able to
detect good payloads you're going to
save this file
and we're going to open it
publisher could not be verified if we
press run and we go back to our Meetup
beta access over here
you can see it has already captured the
URL of an HD server and it is writing
delivering payload
just have to wait for a few seconds so
the payload is delivered
it has sent this much amount of data
meter Peter session one is opened
and we should get the access soon
there we go now to understand where is
the session set
we can write sessions minus I
as you can see it has a meter beta over
here we're going to write sessions minus
I
recession ID is one so we're going to
write 1. and we have the meter beta
access now to get a fair idea of the
system
we're going to write this info and it's
going to the computer name the OS
architecture all these things we can
write the help command to see what are
the things that we can get out of the
system we can take screenshots we can
control the webcam and start a video
chat
we can take a lot of things over here
there are other commands as well where
we can change the file directory like
the cad command CD command there are so
many things that work in the normal CMD
which we can run on the meter beta as
well now if you want to access this
command prompt of the system directly we
can go with this you have to write shell
and there we go we are in the downloads
folder right now to see if this is the
same computer or not we're going to
write ipconfig
as you can see it is our victim machine
with 192.168 or 29.171 we can just press
exit and we're back with the meter beta
access
this is how we can use metafreter and
Metasploit to gain access to a Windows
10 machine next let's take a look at how
we can get to root access from a Windows
10 system
we just learned how we can get a meter
beta access from a system
we can background this meter Builder
session by writing background and
pressing enter
we can still we can still see the
sessions sessions minus I it's still
present over here
now
these kind of access are not
administrative access
these are the kind of back doors that
can be created for standard users but to
get a complete access of a system
including the program files the windows
documents we need to have root access or
administrative access
through that we're going to use another
exploit
reminder that the meter Peter session of
the standard access is already present
and we're not messing with it right now
we're going to set up another session
albeit with the same machine
that exploit name is
use exploit windows
local
bypass UAC
Event Viewer
and there we go now if we check the
options that we can put in the system
we have to choose an exploit Target
we need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
meter beta access with the standard user
it doesn't have the system user
we're going to write
set Session One
and we're going to run export run a few
commands and it opened a second meter
picture session so as you can see it is
the assessment too
if I write this info
you can still see I am not the
system user right now I'm still just a
normal user how can we check that
if you go to Shell
it's still CC users canopy downloads all
these things
if I press exit go back to the meter
bitter there is a command on meter beta
get system it attempts to elevate your
privilege to that of the local system
which basically means you get promoted
into root access so if we write get
system
and due to pipe impersonation we now
have the system root access
as you can see now it has become x64 and
we are the admin users now if I go to
Shell
I can easily go back
windows
and I can easily access these things
this kind of control over the windows
folders and the program files folders
these kind of things are not possible if
you are not an admin access or the
command prompt has not been run with
admin permissions this is how we can use
privilege escalation to get into an
admin access system
we use the second exploit which was the
bypass us Event Viewer exploit
and essentially used it with the first
session as you can read here Windows
escalation USC protection bypass
it was first disclosed on 2016 but it
still works on some systems
this is how we can get a root access on
a Windows 10 installation
Kali net Hunter is the very first
Android penetration testing framework
for Android smartphones
because net Hunter is an open source
project developers can freely utilize it
without fearing copyright infringements
or other threats the project grants
access to the Kali toolkit to compatible
Android devices which allows penetration
testing
furthermore net Hunter provides several
unique capabilities unavailable on other
Hardware platforms
a userline refers to space outside of an
operating system kernel meaning anything
that doesn't have root access we can use
an app to system supported or Nexus or
OnePlus and rooted Android phones
well this is pretty incredible there are
some limitations to this
in general you can communicate with the
instance of whatever Linux device you
want via SSH or VLC using Kali nashanta
the best device for hackers is an
Android phone installed by Kali Linux
because mobile phones are more
convenient and portable than laptops for
personal purposes
the net Center interface also allows
users to work easily with complicated
configuration files through a local web
Apache interface aside from this
functionality modified Kernels at
Android 802.11 wireless injections and
securely link reconfigured VPN Services
comprise a strong network security
breakthrough and a separate Dropbox with
Kali Linux constantly at your disposal
we now have a basic understanding of
what Kali Lil nuts net Hunter is
however there isn't a single
distribution to learn about you can
evidence that Hunter has multiple
different versions depending on the
device at the hands of the users
let's cover them in more detail
so let's cover them in more detail
while Kali net Hunter functions as a
portable operating system designed for
penetration testing there can be other
tools you want that isn't pre-installed
to solve this problem there is a net
Hunter store at the address store.net
hunter.com
this functions the same as a Google Play
Store on Android or app stores on
iPhones except the difference is that
the tools in this repository are more in
line with ethical hacking and 10 broke
penetration
the first of the three versions that net
Hunter provides is the net Hunter
rootless
this works on almost all devices without
any issues the number of tools available
in this version is the lowest among the
three
we then have net until light which
requires root privileges to work
properly it doesn't need any custom
kernel flashing to power up and has
comparatively more tools than net Hunter
rootless
finally we have the original net Hunter
package with all the tools available at
its disposal
however your device must have Privileges
and the custom net Hunter kernel to
install this version
as we can clearly see the more open our
device settings and preferences are the
more tools Kali net Hunter can work with
root privileges provide administrative
access to many functionalities that net
Hunter can leverage and ultimately
perform Network by registration with
some rules are exclusive to the original
electronic core and net Hunter Lite so
you may have to cross check your
requirements before installing any
version on your device
now that we have covered the different
versions of Kali net Hunter let us cover
its different components and how the
help in the working of this distribution
we look at the various net Hunter
components which are effectively the
building pieces of net Hunters operation
the net Hunter's room comprises of
various pieces that communicate and rely
on one another to function properly
below you will look at the three
components that comprise net Hunter
the first is a modified Android kernel
followed by natural Android app and
finally but not least the Kali Linux Chu
itself
let's examine these in depth
the program that provides a UI to
simplify the user's task is a graphical
component of net Hunter which is its
Android
the software provides a straightforward
interface for controlling the Kali Lina
CH rule the fact that it has a simple UI
does not imply that it is not capable of
Performing complex tasks this
application contains all the
configuration files necessary by net
Hunter and is transferred to the SD card
during the first one
aside from the UI the program also
serves as a boot up service allowing the
server to activate when the device boots
up
the next inline is the custom Android
kernel
the kernel is a system component that
allows applications to link to Hardware
that meet users needs aside from
facilitating communication the kernel
also maintains system resources
Now the default kernels inside Android
do not supply at all utilities for
security and exploitation
still with the custom Android kernel any
device can Empower with unique features
which are not accessible in the stock
ones
now we have the Kali CH root
Chu to essentially a full color lens
installation that allows Android to
share network storage and other
resources
is effectively the heart of net Center
and the configuration settings have been
updated so that net Hunter functions
seamlessly with the Android ecosystem
that data has a CH root manager that
simplifies the download and installation
of ch2
this component is stored in an internal
app storage region and one must meet the
installation space requirements
now that you have covered the different
components of Kali net Hunter let us
cover some of the tools the distribution
offers that may be used in penetration
testing
at the top of the chain lies and map
and map stands for network mapper and is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
who also find it useful for tasks such
as Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime it is most beneficial in
the early stage of exploitation where
hacker must figure out the possible
entry point to a system before running
the necessary experts it uses raw IP
packets in novel ways to determine what
hosts are available on the network both
services are being run what hosts are
offering Etc it was designed to scan
large networks but it also works fine
against single hosts
moving on we have the mitm framework
mitm or man in the mug framework
provides a One-Stop shop for man in the
middle and network attacks while
updating and improving existing attacks
and techniques
originally built to address the
significant shortcomings of other tools
it's been almost completely Rewritten
from scratch to provide a modular and
easily extendable framework that anyone
can use to implement their own version
of a man in the middle attack
it contains built-in SMB HTTP and DNS
servers that can be controlled and used
by various plugins
the next tool at hand is the cats
manager it stands for the Kali desktop
experience
Kali net Hunter desktop experience puts
the Kali Linux desktop in the palm of
your hand it provides the graphical user
interface or GUI of Kali desktop on your
Android device making penetration
relatively easier for people not
comfortable with the command line
however the major tools all include
command line functions so this is more
of a convenience inclusion rather than a
functional one
finally we have matters plot the
mattress product framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as Optical hackers to
prove systemic vulnerabilities on
networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems
with matters provide the ethical hacking
team can use ready-made or custom code
and introduce it into a network to probe
for weak response as another paper of
threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions
when I have a very clear understanding
of what Kali net Hunter is and its
features let's cover some of the pros
and cons of this particular framework
when it comes to the advantages
net Hunter provides features that are
not by default included in the original
kernels of Android phones the new tools
can be used to perform Network
penetration and system checks for
security vulnerabilities
Qualcomm Jets and Snapdragon have
monitor support enabled wonder about
help to listen to wireless traffic and
capture data packets which can then be
unencrypted and snooped on
the kernel Builders presence assists the
easy creation of kernels that are not
yet available to the public
similarly the use of gitlab CLI or
command line interface speeds up the
release timelines it allows the input of
other developers making the bugs washing
process easier and the development of
the tools more collaborative
the human interface device Hardware is
fully supported by default but it must
be enabled and configured through user
Space controls
so when it comes to the disadvantages of
Kali net Hunter
so not every Android phone is supported
as part of the official Atlanta release
therefore be cautious while downloading
and running them since the wrong net
Hunter may break the phone in some very
rare circumstances
because some internal Wi-Fi systems do
not allow monitor mode or data packet
injection and external USB Wi-Fi adapter
may be required for some devices who
want to pursue wireless network
penetration if you are interested in
pursuing a career in cyber security and
acquiring the necessary skills then our
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with the MIT University
is surely the right option for you so
hurry up and find the course link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details
first let's understand where and why
nmap is so essential
there are five phases when it comes to
ethical hacking
reconnaissance is the first phase of a
penetration test or ethical hacking
campaign
in this phase the security researcher
collects information about the target it
can be done actively meaning you are
collecting information by sending a
request directly to the Target and
interpreting it or passively meaning
your casting information without
contacting the target directly
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
Network components active machines open
ports operating system details Etc
this activity can be performed by using
information available in the public
domain and by using different tools at
the disposal
the scanning phase is more tool oriented
rather than being performed manually
the penetration tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the target
by using various scanners such as war
dialers port scanners Network mappers
and vulnerability scanners penetration
testers collect as many vulnerabilities
which help in turn attack to a Target in
a more sophisticated way
in this phase the penetration tester
tries to establish a connection with the
Target and explore the vulnerabilities
found in the previous state
the gaining access phase is highly
essential after the scanning phase
exploitation may be buffer overflow
attack denial of service or a Dos attack
session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester extract
information and sensitive data from the
servers by gaining access using
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
backdoor for himself that he can access
later on it helps the penetration tester
in identifying hidden vulnerabilities in
the system while making sure it can be
accessed later on should there be a need
and the covering track phase the
penetration tester tries to remove all
logs and Footprints which help the
administrator identify his presence this
helps the tester to think like a hacker
and perform corrective actions to
mitigate these activities
and map is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits this allows the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and
breach the device
so the reconnaissance and the scanning
phases are the points where nmap finds
most user
let us understand what nmap is from a
Layman's perspective
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime
the program is most commonly used via
command line interface and is available
for many different operating systems
such as Linux free PST and gen 2. its
popularity has also been bolstered by an
active and enthusiastic user support
community
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits
initially developed for Enterprise scale
networks it can scan through thousands
of connected devices however in recent
years nmap has become increasingly
popular among smaller companies as well
and map user DB packets in novel ways to
determine what hosts are available on
the network what services these hosts
are offering what operating systems they
are running what type of packet filters
or firewalls are in use and dozens of
other characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fine against single host as well
the rise of iot in particular now means
that networks used by these companies
have become more complex and therefore
harder to secure
this means that nmap is now used in many
website monitoring tools to audit the
traffic between web servers and iot
devices
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
the recent emergence of iot botnets have
also stimulated interest in nmap not
least because of its ability to
interrogate devices connected by the
UPnP protocol but also to highlight any
devices that may be malicious
now that we understand what nmap is let
us take a look at the workflow of how an
ethical hacker uses this tool in
penetration testing
at a practical level nmap is used to
provide detailed real-time information
on your networks and on the devices that
are connected to them
we have the hacker running nmap on his
own system with a victim machine running
a standard installation of their
operating system which can be either
Windows Mac OS Linux or any other
variation
the first stage consists of the hacker
sending some IP packets to the victim
machine directly these are specially
crafted IP packets which are necessary
of some reply
after getting these packets the victim
machine tends to send some reply back to
the machine that had sent these requests
which is in turn a hacker
whatever reply the machine sends back to
nmap it can later be used for analysis
depending on what kind of requests are
being sent and the manner of the replies
that are received one can determine
easily what kind of machine we are
taking up it can be used to determine
the life of the host which basically
means if the host is alive or currently
if the server is shut down we can check
what posts are opened and we can also
know what type of services are being
offered on those specific ports many
applications like FTP and Samba run on
specific ports thereby if we find those
posts open one can determine that these
services are being run on the victim
machine
we can also find the operating system
which is being run on the victim with
the specific scan filters using nmap
we are now aware of how nmap works at a
basic level
but there are many varieties of scans
that users can run on local machines
each of them serves a different purpose
let's take a look at some of these scans
being sleep is the simple time of nmap
scan where it brings to all available IP
addresses to check which IPS respond to
icmp or Internet control message
protocol
if the users need to know only the
number of IP addresses and not many
details the pink sweep is very useful
this is Fast and the results are known
to be fetched very easily
syn is the most useful type of nmap scan
which does work quietly it sends a syn
packet via TCP or transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgment pack is received back to
the system it is sure that a port is
open there no response means that the
port is either closed or not available
here the difference is that the full
connection is done by sending the
acknowledgment packets back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
but need more power from the machines to
do the work
this is more accurate than syn scans too
if all the access is related to os are
available to the user it is better to do
a TCP scan than an SYM as well as all
the low and high level accesses that are
required for this
the network is also loaded more hence
users must be careful about loading the
system and the networks
an ideal scan is really used to check
whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular Network
this is the most recent type of nmap
scan where the scan packets are sent to
a port when moved away by another host
to check the presence of malware
RPC scans also known as remote procedure
calls are done by hackers to make the
system vulnerable to virus attacks this
is necessary to know whether a system
answers such calls and makes our systems
open to malware
RPC scan is done to check this by
finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by RPC
a Windows scan is a simple scan where
the application scans the acknowledgment
packets received from the ports once syn
packages are sent if there are any
abnormalities in the ack package
received which is the acknowledgment the
scan reports the same and helps in
recognizing which ports are functioning
in a different way
the bound scan is used to check the
security in the file transfer protocol
layer
FTP layers mostly do not accept any
packets and once it is ejected from the
FTP layers there are chances that it
might be sent to an internal layer so
that it can access the machines
bounce can check this loophole by doing
exactly the same process and identifies
whether FTP layer is open to this
vulnerability or not
the UDP scan is most useful in the
windows system to know whether the UDP
layer is open to attacks you it is not
always possible to get a response from
the UDP layer but it helps to know
whether the layer is having any Trojan
attacks running in it the responses can
be a bit slower than other scans but it
is useful to do this scan to protect it
it responds to packets when the port is
closed which might make the sender
believe that there is a presence of
Trojan so it is good to double check the
same
the fin scan is similar to syn scan by
the system that sends the package
receives the response back and it will
be mostly TCP fin packets
if the system sends an rst packet it is
a false alarm and users need not be
worried about the same
null scan is useful for other systems
than Windows where the systems can
easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets or null responses
null scans are not useful for Windows as
they may not always produce the desired
results
there is a wide range of free network
monitoring utilities as well as free
open source vulnerability scanners which
are available to admins and security
Auditors but mix and Maps stand out as
the tool it and network managers need to
know is its flexibility and Power
there are some alternatives to nmap but
most of them are focused on providing
specific Niche functionality that
average system administrator does not
need frequently
Mass scan for instance Edge must faster
than nmap but it provides much less
detail as well
in reality nmap provides all the
functionality and speed that the average
user requires especially when used along
with other similar tools we also have
netcat which can be used to manage and
control Network traffic and Zen map
which is basically a graphical user
interface for nmap but as an all-rounder
solution to network scanning nobody can
go wrong with nmap as the tool of choice
let us now take a tour of nmap based on
all the things we have covered today
we start by learning of how to install
an end map on a fresh operating system
that doesn't come pre-installed with the
tool
we also cover some different types of
scans that can be run on local machines
along with checking the multiple
inferences and ethical hacker can gather
based on the scan output of nmaps
finally we run scans on vulnerable
machines to get an idea of how to
proceed with the outputs We Gather using
this tool the first step in our
demonstration is installing nmap
now it depends heavily on what Linux
distribution you are going to use to
perform ethical hacking
right now I am using parrot security
operating system if you are not aware of
what parrot security is or even what
Kali Linux is we highly suggest that you
check out the videos of those two
operating systems on our YouTube channel
so that you can get a fair idea of what
they serve
now if you are using any of these two
operating systems and Maps should come
pre-installed by default
to check if nmap is pre-installed or not
you can just press on applications over
here
go to the pen testing section
go to this information gathering tab
and you should be able to see nmap right
here now let's say you do not have nmap
pre-installed maybe using a Linux
distribution like Ubuntu or Linux Mint
or something that is based on Debian
operating systems
one thing you have to make sure that
nmap should be in the distribution
Repository
once you check that or even if you do
not know if it is present it should be
sudo which is to give the root
permissions for installation
apt
APD is the package manager of all Linux
distributions that are based on Debian
that goes for Debian stable Ubuntu Linux
Mint Kali Linux paired security and
anything of that nature
apt is the package manager which handles
the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems
once you're here just write install
and and map
press enter and it's going to ask you
for the root password that is sent when
you install the operating system in the
first place
enter your root password and press enter
again
as you can see it's saying that nmap is
already installed the newest version
since I am running pirate security
operating system
now should you be running this operating
system or even garlic Linux you should
receive a similar message and the
installation is already done if you are
using some other distribution let's say
even black arcs Arch Linux or Manjaro
anything like that
the installation steps will be slightly
different this sudo apt install nmap
command is for distributions that are
derived from Debian and Ubuntu if you
want to install in Arch Linux based
distributions you have to use their
package manager which is known as pamac
but that is for a different step and if
you want to get ethical hacking the best
way to start is by learning either Kali
Linux or parrot security
now that the installation is done
we're going to learn how to use nmap
one of the most basic functions of nmap
is to identify active hosts on the
network
we can do this by using a ping scan the
ping scan identifies all of the IP
addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts
now to run the ping scan we're going to
write nmap
the flag we're going to mention over
here is sp now these flags are the
different
traits of the nmap scan depending on
what flag we use we can send different
kinds of requests to the host that we
are scanning now before moving forward
with this let me open another terminal
over here and check the IP address
going to write the command ifconfig and
find the Subnet in which this system is
present
as you can see the IP address is 192.168
0.72.131
now this operating system is being run
on a virtual machine software known as
VMware the VMware in itself is running
on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of
parrot security
and the Windows operating system which
is the host system in my scenario will
fall in this particular subnet
so to run a scan
we're going to Target
192.16
it's 72.1-24
this command then returns a list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned IP addresses
this is going to be capital p
yeah
if you spot any host or IP addresses on
that list that you cannot account for
you can then run further commands to
investigate them further
as of right now you can see the machine
that is the parrot security
this IP address can be detected in the
subnet
the
192.168.72.1 is my local Windows machine
that is running VMware software and
ultimately this virtual machine
the 72.2 is the DHCP server that hosts
the internet connection of the parrot
security this we can ignore for now
now the Windows machine that we have
over here let's run some tests on that
going to clear
a terminal
and you can close this actually
when scanning hosts nmap commands can
use server names ipv for addresses or
IPv6 addresses
a basic and map command
will produce information about the given
host
to run the basic port scan we can just
use nmap along with the IP now as you
remember
the IP
is 192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my
local Windows 10 machine
as you can see
it shows the ports that are opened and
the particular service that these ports
are running
now we can also have a detection of the
operating system
now mind you this is not 100 correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation and what kind of
fingerprinting measures are available
now since this does tcpip fingerprinting
it needs some extra permissions the flag
that we are going to use is nmap minus o
along with the same IP address
like I said since this is TCP
fingerprinting it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the
nmap
and sudo keyword
going to repeat the same command that we
wrote above
as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows 10.
with this Mac address
it has also shown the correct build
number of the Windows 10 system that I
am using
this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated
now to get the necessary information
about these services for example what
versions they are using we have a
command known as SV which stands for
service version
we use the same IP address
and press enter
now as you can see
the scan is complete and if you can
check the results of the scan above here
we don't see any version number for the
services
here we can actually check what version
they are running now this becomes
helpful when we are trying to find
specific versions to exploit for example
a VMA workstation
16.1.2 had some particular vulnerability
we can exploit it by checking this
command
apart from the host scanning Port
scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are a few ways that this
command can be customized as well
for example
I have already checked that the 443
command is open
but I have found out after running this
lengthy scan let's say I only want to
check if command if the port 443 is open
and map
but I'm going to use the
flag of minus P which stands for Port
and give 443 as an argument here
using the same IP address
and you can see it says it's open
but we already knew it is open let's say
there was something else
if let's say we're going to scan if the
Apache web server port is open which
usually runs on 80.
obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's closed
now we can combine these two commands by
running both both simultaneously to do
that we can just put a comma
foreign
expected it is closed and 443 is open
another feature of nmap for both
scanning is showing of ranges
now ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example nmap minus B we're going to
check what ports are open between 100
to let's say 2000
this acts as a range
everything else is the same
and it checks all ports in the range of
100 to 2000.
whatever post is open in between that
range it can be mentioned over here
we're going to clear the screen now
another flag that can be used with nmap
is the SS command
this runs a stealth scan which is a
little harder to detect if you're the it
admin of the system that is being
scan
the results will more or less be the
same although this will need elevated
root privileges
2.1
as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan which just adds
an extra mac address as well for good
measure but like I said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked
stealth scans are relatively tougher to
check on much more intricate systems
this takes longer as well
now that we're done with both scanning
let's look at a vulnerable machine
the system that is scanning right now is
this my own personal system with
everything is pretty locked down as much
as it can be
there is an attack box running
in the cloud the IP address of which is
over here
now to be able to get into this network
we need to connect to their personal
network using a VPN
so what I'm going to do is switch to a
different workspace over here
I'm going to open a terminal
and if you can see over here there is a
hacktest.o VPN file
I'm going to connect to their VPN
network using this ovpn file
and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been established
like we discussed this is the vulnerable
device IP
we're going to copy this
and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal
I'm going to try to Ping this and check
if we are able to reach this machine
and as you can see we're getting a reply
back which means we are now part of the
local network
where the vulnerable machine is present
let's run a service scan map
with the respective versions
we ran the similar scan on my local
machine where we were able to detect
what version each service was running
what we're going to do over here is by
checking what kind of services are open
on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if
nmap alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the machine
as you can see the scan is now completed
and we have some of the ports that are
being opened over here and what kind of
service they are running
now
like we discussed this is the first
stage or sometimes even the second stage
of ethical hacking
what we can infer from here is what are
the services that are being run now
these two ports 139 and 445 are actually
Windows SMB server ports which are above
the windows Samba server
now every service has a particular
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you may use Apache
server will always run on Port 80 SMB
servers will function on these two ports
now assembly servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known
as of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the SMB server open it's
worth a shot that we try that exploit on
this machine
now to start the exploit on this you're
going to open another terminal over here
and we're going to use Metasploit for
trying the exploit there
we're going to write sudo msf console
msf console is the keyword first
launching the Metasploit console
enter the root password and wait for
Mattress plug to Launch
other than the ports we can also see
that it has
checked the host name of the system
and the operating system as well
now that the meta spot is open
we're going to launch the exploit
now before launching we're going to have
to check what exploits are there for the
Eternal blue vulnerability
we're going to write use exploit
blue and we're going to check what kind
of results we are getting over here
as you can see
serial number nine exploit Windows SMB
ms17010 internal blue it was first
disclosed in 2017. and assembly remote
kernel pool corruption
let's say we're going to use this
particular exploit now all of this may
be confusing if you are not aware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part
we're going to use
exploit number nine as we found above
to use exploit number nine
we're going to set a payload
which is our malicious code that will
run
on the vector machine
now we're going to check
some options
as you can see it has by default pointed
to the 445 Port since that is the port
where SMB server can be accessed from
the parameter that's missing over here
is our host the r host is the IP address
of the vulnerable machine basically the
machine in which we want to attack
now I'm going to use the set command
to set the IP address
now if we check
we now have
a victim IP address set
another parameter that we can change is
the L Host this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you remember
we had connected using a VPN
so we're going to be assign a new IP
according to the VPN so if we write
ifconfig
and check this one Tu 1 0 is the VPN
adapter this is our IP address that we
have been assigned in the server in the
network where the vulnerable machine is
present so we're going to copy this IP
address
you will get to move over this workspace
and we're going to set L host
with that IP address
with that our options are set now we're
going to run exploit
and it's going to check if Samba server
vulnerability is present
as you can see it has written that the
target is vulnerable to this particular
exploit
it's going to send the malicious code
and the malicious code is set in the
payload that you sent above
and we now have the shell command of the
Windows machine
as you can see see Windows system 32.
to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ipconfig which is a
Windows only shell command
as you can see this is the IP address
that was assigned
to the victim I victim machine
now
while the major part of this process was
done on Metasploit
we would not have reached the stage had
we not found out that the 139 and 445
ports are open which basically pointed
us that we can drive the Eternal blue
exploit of the windows Samba servers
similarly all the scans that we run
serve as a preface to the actual stages
or the actual hacking stages of the
campaigns
this SV command was necessary because we
could check what are the exact services
that are being running in some cases if
the if it Apache server is being run
there are particular versions which have
particular exploits those exploits will
not work on other versions so we're
going to have to check what particular
version is being run and accordingly
apply the exploit that can be done in
the matters plot or you can run some
other tool but what exact exploit you
have to run and which vulnerability we
have to Target that is where nmap comes
to help
first let's understand the importance of
knowing programming for hacking you
might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cyber security career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that do
keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top 5 programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example OS modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security Integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them python has a massive
community that helps with third-party
plugins every day it is also an easy to
read language with a simple syntax this
will be helpful for beginners you can
easily write automation scripts using
Python and it also makes prototyping
much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have JavaScript
currently JavaScript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of JavaScript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitations since most of their web
apps use JavaScript or one of its
libraries
knowing JavaScript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
JavaScript can be used to read saved
cookies and Security Experts also use
JavaScript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
JavaScript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
JavaScript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially JavaScript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use JavaScript to Snoop
the type towards inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is PHP
hypertext preprocessor or PHP is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand PHP as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you are into web hacking
then getting your hands on PHP would be
an asset PHP is used in server-side
scripting using PHP you could write a
custom application that modifies
settings on a web server and makes a
Target server susceptible to attacks
with the help of PHP you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
PHP is one of the most powerful
server-side languages used in most of
the web domains this shows how learning
PHP can help you with web hacking and
also help you fight against malicious
attackers
popular content Management Systems run
on a foundation of PHP hence having a
strong knowledge of PHP can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is SQL
SQL is the acronym for structured query
language although SQL is not a
traditional programming language it is a
language used for only communicating
with databases
several systems like MySQL postgresql
store their data in databases
SQL is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of SQL lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
SQL is used for the purpose of web
hacking SQL is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into a large databases
it will be impossible to contract
database attacks without a good
understanding of SQL
using SQL hackers can perform an attack
known as SQL injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
SQL is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on SQL
injection
SQL injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
View and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number five we have the C
programming language
it is no surprise that we have C the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development the low-level nature of C
provides an edge over other programming
languages used for hacking
a hacker can use the C programming
language to his or her Advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level Hardware
components such as the ram
Security Professionals mostly you see
when they are required to manipulate
system resources and Hardware
C also helps penetration testers write
programming Scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in C language hence
learning C you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
C is also used to create shell codes
rootkates exploits built undetectable
malware keyloggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both C and C plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top 5 programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
Master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have Ruby the Ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now there can be a
close comparison drawn between Ruby and
python based on its syntax however Ruby
is more web focused
Ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits Ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master Ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know Ruby
second we have Pearl although Pearl has
lost its old Fame it still holds value
in the hacker Community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on Perl
as it was the go-to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate Linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
pull code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is HTML many of you
might have wondered why we didn't
mention HTML yet yes no programming list
is complete without mentioning HTML
the hypertext markup language HTML is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glues the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web this shows
the importance HTML has
an understanding of HTML is vital to
play with web applications
HTML also Finds Its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
HTML is a must if you want to master
this field having said that HTML is not
that tough a language to learn hence it
is advised to master HTML if you want to
compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language it is undoubtedly one of the
most powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn it is a complicated
low level programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine Hardware or
software using it
Assembly Language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and Trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse Engineers use Assembly Language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as the language sounds
the results it produces are highly
fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
Security Professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals if you're interested in
pursuing a career in cyber security and
acquiring the necessary skills then our
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with the MIT University
is surely the right option for you so
hurry up and find the course link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details
now that we understand the basis of
ethical hackers let's go over how python
came into existence and its features
python is a computer programming
language often used to build websites
and software
it can also be used to automate tasks
and conduct data analysis
python is a general purpose language
meaning it can be used to create a
variety of different programs and isn't
specialized for any specific problem
this versatility along with its beginner
friendliness has made it one of the most
used programming languages today
a survey conducted by industry analyst
firm Brad monk found that it was the
most popular programming languages among
developers in 2020
python is commonly used for developing
websites and software task automation
data analysis and data visualization
since it's relatively easy to Learn
Python has been adopted by many
non-programmers such as accountants and
scientists for a variety of everyday
tasks like organizing finances
it has become a staple in data science
allowing data analysts and other
professionals to use the language to
conduct complex statistical calculations
creating data visualizations build
machine learning algorithms manipulate
and analyze data and complete other data
related tasks
python however is mostly used to create
scripts rather than full-scale programs
a python script the file containing the
commands is structured to be executed
like a program these files are designed
to contain various functions and import
various modules
python interactive shell or the
respective command line is used to
execute the script to perform a specific
task a script is structured by defining
the set of function definitions and then
stating the main program used to call
the functions
program consists of numerous tasks these
tasks can be executed with the help of
scripts unlike libraries scripts can be
used without importing and are less code
intensive
python variable assignment is different
from some of the popular languages there
is no Declaration of a variable just an
assignment statement when we declare a
variable in C or C plus plus or any
other unlike languages this sets aside
an area of memory for holding values
allotted by the data type of the
variable the memory allocated will be
interpreted as the data type suggests at
compile time initial value will be
checked
so we cannot mix the data types in
between but python is a dynamically
typed language it doesn't know about the
type of the variable until the code is
run so the Declaration is of no use what
it does is it stores that value at some
memory location and then binds the
variable name to that memory container
this makes the contents of the container
accessible through that variable name so
the data type does not matter
it will get to know the type of the
value during runtime
python also offers multiple options for
developing GUI or graphical user
interface out of all the GUI methods
decanter is the most commonly used
method it is a standard python interface
to the TK GUI toolkit shipped with
python python with decanter is the
fastest and easiest way to create GUI
applications
Python programming languages is widely
used by companies around the world to
build web apps analyze data automate
operations via devops and create
reliable scalable Enterprise
applications
many companies do not even realize they
are using python across the
organizations for example if a company
is a Java only company but they use ibmf
sphere as a web application server then
they have to use Python to script the
server's configuration
python has a habit of getting in
everywhere regardless of whether the
usage is intentional
big names like Microsoft Netflix Google
Uber and Dropbox regularly use python in
the software framework development
now that we understand Python's basic
functionality let's cover some of its
advantages when compared to Industry
counterparts
when it comes to third-party modules the
python package index also known as pypi
contains several third-party modules
that allow python to communicate with
the majority of other languages and
system
it has functions that are separate to
the python code base and has many extra
capabilities that can be activated later
on
python also contains a vast Android
library that covers topics such as
string operations internet protocols web
services tools and OSI interfaces
many joint programming tasks have
already been coded into the standard
Library considerably reducing the amount
of code that a new developer must write
python is open source due to a lack of
official technical support which has
driven the establishment of communities
that increase the Resource Bank for the
language's continuing growth and
acceptance its source code development
is partnered with multiple coders and
receives Community feedback well
features are often shared with the
community to Garner feedback before
pushing them onto the main branch
python includes built-in data structures
such as lists and dictionaries that may
be used to create quick runtime data
structures
furthermore python has added benefit of
dynamic high-level data typing
decreasing the support code length
required
data structures are the set of data
elements that produce a well-organized
way of storing and organizing the data
in the computer so that it can be useful
for example the data structures like
stack queue linked list Etc are mostly
used in the field of computer science
artificial intelligence and Graphics Etc
we have now covered all the features
python offers and the basic
functionalities
let's write some real-time python code
that can crack passwords using Python's
libraries
in this demo we will write two blocks of
code both of which offer a unique way to
break passwords the first one is a Brute
Force attack the other is a dictionary
attack
the difference with Brute Force attack
is that in brute force a large number of
possible key permutations are checked
whereas in the dictionary attack only
the words with the most possibilities of
success are checked and are less time
consuming than Brute Force
so let's jump into the code editor now
the code editor we are using today is
spy charm
pycharm serves as an IDE for running
Python program specifically and can be
downloaded for free as a community
Edition
now the first thing we're going to start
is by importing some libraries
the first one would be
the random Library
this one would be necessary to generate
the random choices from which the
password will be guessed
next we're going to import another
Library
known as P by Auto g y
this is necessary to generate a
graphical user interface but the user
will be asked to enter the password to
be cracked
next we're going to create a variable
called as
cache
this will hold the number of characters
it will store all the characters which
can be used in our password
so we're going to start with
all the alphabets
and just to be safe we're going to add
all the digits as well from 0 to 9. now
this can be expanded further to include
special characters but we're going to
skip that for this example
next we're going to turn this variable
into a list this is necessary so that we
can Traverse the list accordingly
so we're going to create a new variable
all okay
and convert this into
a list
and there we go
regarding the user they are asked to
enter a password that needs to be
cracked the password will be entered
into a graphical user interface and can
be stored in a variable
let's take it as PWD
we're going to use the py auto GUI
function to generate the GUI the type of
input will be a password input so that
the values entered are not visible
we're going to write a message such as
enter a password
and that's it
let's keep the semicolon over here
the user will see this message on the
graphical user interface and can then
enter a password
now the passwords that are being guessed
need to be stored somewhere so we're
going to create a sample
PWD password
and just enter
a null value to go with
now we're going to start generating
random values that need to be checked
for that we're going to use a while loop
and the condition that we're going to
run is sample password which will be our
guest password should not be equal to
PWD which is the original password now
this Loop will run as long as the values
are not same the moment the sample
password which is a password guest and
Generator randomly becomes equal to the
original password this Loop will be
closed and the program will be over
so we're going to start generating by
assigning the value to sample PWD is
equal to going to use the random dot
choices function
and the arguments we're going to pass as
all cap which is the list of all the
values that need to be checked or more
like all the characters that can be used
to Generate random choices and for the
length we're going to assign a value of
K which will be the length of the
original password
the original password which is entered
we're going to check the length using
the Len function and make sure that the
random choices function generates
passwords of that lens specifically now
we can skip this so that it checks for
all the possible variations and all the
different lengths but that will take
time so we're going to stick with
something small for this example
next we're going to print out a message
where we can see the number of values
that are being checked
we can put up a simple message
such as this
we're going to check the string value of
sample PWD
and we're going to close the message
that's it
now this is the one that generates the
random choices we also have to check the
choices with the original password so
we're going to set up an if condition
over here
and we're going to write if sample PWD
is the same as PWD or we have to use the
list version
of PWD since sample PWD in itself will
be a list
if it is true we're going to print
the password
is
going to put up a space
I'm going to join
the new one
this will display the guest password
we can break over here so that we run
out of the if condition and the loop now
let's run this code once
to run mean
okay as you can see we have missed a
colon sign over here in the while
function
so we're going to run it now
as you can see we have the GUI that is
asking the password for us
now we can give a small password so that
we can see if it's working or not
we're going to write
PC2 and since we have given the data
being input as dot password it's not
going to show what is being entered over
here
I have entered the password of a b c 1.
so press OK and you can see it's going
to check the combinations of four digit
passwords now this doesn't follow a
specific order
so this works on generating random
choices we can create programs that goes
a specific order as a single permutation
like we're going to start from zero zero
zero and move on to zero zero zero one
that's typically how normally Brute
Force password crackers work but this is
easier to examine and we can see how the
program is being worked on using this
if we're going to stop it for now
and give it another try
going to run mean
I'm going to try something else
and you can see it keeps running up the
same program and this time I ends enter
the password of abc2 and you can see in
one of those random choices it did find
out my password like I said we can do
this using a systematic method where it
goes from the first option to the very
last one but this is more easier to
explain and more easier to visualize as
a first program
now regarding our next program which is
going to be a dictionary attack a
dictionary attack uses a word list a
word list will cons will have a list of
passwords that can be used or a list of
possible outcomes
we're going to start
by importing some libraries on its own
here we need to use only import hashlip
because the password that we are going
to enter will be a hashed version we're
not going to give the plain text
password in an input like we did in the
previous program so to work on those
hash and the functions that are
necessary to work on those hashes we're
going to use this Library
we also want to set up a counter
of pass found
this is necessary to know if the
password has been found or not when we
do find the right password we can change
the value of this counter and the
program and The Interpreter will know
that our program has been completed
the password that the user will enter
needs to be in a hash format so we're
going to keep it in a variable known as
let's say I hash
we're going to ask the user for the
input
enter the
hashed password
and there we go
next
we're going to use the word list over
here to use the word list we need to
open it how can we do that let's take up
a variable known as
P dock
we're going to ask the user for an input
going to move on to the next line using
the backslash n command and write
enter
password file name
including path
so what we are asking over here is we're
going to ask the user for a particular
path in the local system where the file
has been opened up
once the user gives the file name path
we can open it and store it in a file
let's say p file
and we're going to use the file option
functionalities of python okay
now it is of python
we're going to use the path stored in
pdoc and open in read mode only
next we're going to set up our Loop
which is going to check every single
password with the hashed password we're
going to use a for Loop we're going to
carry out every word in the open file
over here
next as we know we have received a
hashed value of the password we need to
convert it into standard terms before we
can start comparing
first what we have to do is we have to
encode the hashed password into a common
variable known as the utf-8 standard now
there's a good chance that it is by
default in utf-8 encoding but running
this line helps us in being sure that
the next few lines work correctly
we're going to store another variable
known as hash word
this is after the encoding
where we're going to use another hashlip
function which is the md5
so that we can convert the value
found in ENC word
and keep it in a hashed format
now that we have made it clear that we
now the hash can be read and run by the
computer we're going to get the final
hash digest of it now to strip the hash
digest we're going to store it in our
value let's say of name Digest
we will use the value generated above in
hash word
and right
hex Digest
this will generate the hash digest of
the password and create store it in this
digest variable now
we have the digest so we can start
comparing it to the password file that
we have found so going to write a loop
such as if digest is equal to the input
hash which is the hashed password that
the user input
then
we can just print
password
found
which we can then
show
using whatever value has been extracted
right now from the password file or the
word list
we're also going to change the variable
of the pass found counter to 1 and we're
going to break
now let's say that we do not find a
password
we have to inform the user that the
password is not found in the particular
word list so we're going to write
another loop let's say if not
pass found
now think of it from a systematic way
the default value of pass found is zero
let's say we do find the password in the
word list the value is getting changed
to 1. so at this point of time the value
of password should be 1 if the password
has been found
if not 1 which basically implies if 0.
since 1 is considered as true and 0 is
considered as false if it is 1 this part
of the if condition will not be executed
this part will only be executed if no
password is found and by default the
value of pass found is 0 so if not 0
will turn into F1 which is supposed to
be true and the following lens will be
executed
so the next few lines we're going to
print that the password was not found
and we can start running the program
foreign
now to generate the hashed password
we're going to use an online tool and as
the md5 hash generator.com now let's say
our user password is the same as the one
we used in the last program which is
abc2
we're going to generate the hash
we're going to copy the md5 hash over
here press on copy
and we're going to paste Ctrl V and
press enter now this password file name
is asking for the location of the word
list now I have stored the word list in
my D drive with the name of P1 dot txt
this file has a list of passwords which
also include the word abc2 in there
so go to press enter
as you can see it has found the password
abc2 after doing the hash
functionalities over here
now if you were to remove it
let's say we're going to use our wrong
password for example
if you're going to create a new value
such as of ABC 5.
and take this new hash value
we're going to rerun this program
and we're going to use a new hash value
which is not present in the current word
list
as you can see we are now getting the
expected password node Pawn
functionality
so this way the password has been
cracked open with two different types of
attacks using a brute force and a
dictionary attack since this type of
methodology works on a word list this is
known as a dictionary attack as it has a
source of passwords where it can check
the possible outcomes from
so let's begin with what is SQL
injection
as the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject Mauritius input into a SQL
statement so SQL stands for structured
query language which is a language used
by an application to interact with the
database now normally this attack is
targeted towards a database to extract
the data that is stored within however
the vulnerability does not lie in the
database itself the vulnerability will
always lie in the application
it is the developer's prerogative of how
to develop the application how to
configure it to prevent SQL injection
queries from happening a database is
created to answer questions and if a
question is asked it is supposed to
answer it database needs to be
configured for some amount of security
but the vulnerability the flaw here for
SQL injection will always lie in the
application itself it does how the
application interacts with the database
that needs to be modified that needs to
be maintained by the developer rather
than just configuring the database
itself so the attacker at this point in
time when they send a query to the
application will form a malformed query
by injecting a particular command or an
operator that is recognized by the SQL
language and if that operator is passed
through the application to the database
then the database basically gets cracked
or does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called ovasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this on
till this power is on I'm going to show
you where we can download this utility
from so you can just
look for ovasp broken web application
project download you'll find it on
sourcefold.net click on the link
you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9 GB download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or every
Oracle virtual box
now this is an application that has been
developed by ovasp which stands for open
web application security project which
is a not-for-profit organization and
periodically releases the most top 10
risks that an application uh will face
for that particular year
so they have given a web application
with inbuilt vulnerabilities for
professionals like us to practice upon
to developables our skills upon because
doing this in the real world is illegal
I cannot go onto a website to
demonstrate how a SQL injection attack
works uh neither should you try your
hands on it till you become very well
rehearsed with it so till to upgrade
your skills to upskill yourself please
download this machine host it in a
VMware Workstation or a Oracle virtual
box and you can uh then try your skills
on it right so just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71.132
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192 168 71.132
and you'll see the OS broken web
application project and there are a lot
of training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutility over here
uh this gives you the uh OS top 10 risks
for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so
far uh but the difference between 2013
and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection
attacks blind SQL injection and then
there is a tool called SQL map which is
available freely on on your Linux
machines Kali Linux or parrot Linux
whichever you want to use uh for your
practice targets and so on so forth so
if I just take you here for bypass
Authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may have right you look at a
username you look at password you type
that in and you log in so let's say I
don't know a password here I'm just
going to type in the username test
password is
passwrd I'll try to log in and it shows
me that the account does not exist so
the authentication mechanism does work I
did try type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single quote
or one equals one space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it gives me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and we're going to look at the
basics of SQL injection so looking at
that small demo looking now let's look
at what types of secret injections are
available so the first is inbound SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within in band error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a time-based attack and the
third one is out of bound SQL injection
attack now what is n-band SQL injection
attack in bandage where we are either
attempting the error base or the union
base what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and it generates an
error message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that makes us realize that there
is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union base is it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember the username we gave it a
single quote or one equals one space
hyphen hyphen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was this a single quote is an operator
that goes to the database selects the
default uh table in the user tables in
this database column and then Compares
it to the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was of 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default user table that
was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or one equals one hyphen iPhone space
and login you can see that this is a
correct condition and thus we are able
to log in now before we even go to that
extent if I just forget the condition
over here and it just give it a single
quote the operator and I send this
operator to the database and I click on
login you will see that it generates an
error which is right on top and it tells
us the line the file the error happened
and you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler.php file right and then it gave
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the manual that
corresponds to yours MySQL server
version for the right syntax to use now
why would a hacker want to do this in
the first place because there are
different types of databases so there is
a MySQL Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle
SQL IBM db2 all of these are variations
of the SQL database they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right there they have their
own syntax they have their own specific
commands that are utilized for the
database so in this scenario the hacker
wants to identify what database is being
currently utilized so they can craft
those particular queries so now with
this injection with just me sending the
quote and the error getting generated I
now come to know that we are using a
MySQL server and the version of that
server is 5.1.73 and the rest of the
information about uh where the handlers
are located and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so error base attack is where you
generate these kind of Errors uh and you
get this information the union base is
where you craft your queries within the
URL or you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
when we come to Boolean based SQL
injection uh sends a SQL query to the
database which forces the application to
return a different wizard depending on
whether the query runs it true or a
false result so basically if the input
is false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false there's
one input that is false the other input
that is true input B the output would be
true and so on so forth right so
depending on the result from the inputs
the attacker will come to know which
input is true with this you can then
access the database of the website so
you're trying to figure out by sending
out multiple inputs and then analyzing
the output to see what exactly which
command exactly worked what was the
resultant output of that command thus
from this kind of an information the
hacker can infer their next step forward
then you have time based SQL injections
uh now there are times when a database
administered or an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and thus have disabled
verbose error messages now what is a
verbose error message the error message
that we saw right here
is a verbose error message that means
that the message gives out details the
message gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if
they have sanitized these errors
and you no longer can generate these
errors and thus you cannot figure out
what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply learn
okay
foreign
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbose error that we saw
here so this gives us a detail error of
what went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
where the query went wrong and etc etc
etc whereas on this side where there's
some there's a lot of security that goes
in here so you can see that it doesn't
generate a error it just get a generic
page in front of you so in that case
what does a hacker do so the hacker then
injects a time-based
uh query in the URL which allows us to
verify whether the command is being
executed or not so we put in a Time
weight
let's say 10 seconds of time weight so
if we the moment we inject the query if
the query times for 10 seconds and then
gets executed that means that the SQL
injection is possible however
if we inject the query and it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled in the database management
system that has been used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error by the database
administrator where you have enabled
functions and not sanitize them so you
have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be executed a user level
with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions
to be to be enabled at the dbms and
there is an administrative account that
can have access to them at that point in
time and out of bound injection attack
is possible so let's look at how our
website works right uh how SQL works on
a website now the website is constructed
of HTML hypertext markup language which
would include JavaScript for
functionality cascading style sheets for
the mapping of the website right and
then the react.js and whatnot uh for for
the functionality now when we send a
query to the website it is normally
using the HTTP protocol or https
protocol when the query reaches the
application the application would then
go ahead and generate the SQL query uh
at the client side you'll have all these
scripting languages coming in on the
front end that we can utilize to craft
queries and then send them across at the
server side you will have uh databases
like Oracle MySQL MSC well and so on so
forth that will then execute those
queries right so just to give you an
example if I use a tool called Postman
what we generally do when we craft a
query is we send out a get request
to the website and then we'll see a
response from the site with the HTML
code and everything so this is a tool
that is utilized by software testers to
test the responses that you're going to
get from various websites so yeah on the
left hand side you can see I've used it
on quite a bit uh here we have an
example for gmail.com so let's continue
with that so this is a get request being
sent to Gmail the moment I sent it is
going to create an HTTP request and send
it across the response that I get is
this this is the HTML code for gmail.com
right these are the cookies these are
the headers that include information so
it you can see this is a text HTML
character set utilized is utf-8 and the
configuration uh that has been done with
the application right so this is where
uh everything comes in this is the
cookie that has been sent with that
particular request that I had sent out
now if you Analyze This query right so
when we went on to this application and
I typed in that single quote and we
generated this error right uh you can
see that the application converted this
into a SQL query so the query was select
username from accounts where the
username in quote single quotes and we
use this code right the single code
right there so uh that's where we use
that operator and that's where the
exception error occurred so these are
the kind of queries that are structured
by the application and then taken on to
the database for execution when we type
in uh it is a HTTP get request with the
username and password within that query
that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a SQL query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response so how do we prevent SQL
injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries these statements make sure that
the parameters pass into SQL statements
are treated in a safe manner so for
example we saw that the single code was
an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place right so here what we
are doing here is a secure way of
running a SQL query in the jdbc using a
parameterized statement Define which
user we want to find so there's a string
the email comes in connection to the
database we are going to figure out how
the connection is going to be passed how
it is going to be created construct the
SQL statement we want to run specifying
the parameter right so we Define how is
it going to be uh created what is going
to be created what can be passed to the
database and what should not be passed
to the database so that is one way of
utilizing prepaid statements and
parameterized queries
where we have object relational mapping
most development teams prefer to use
objection object relational mapping
Frameworks to evade the translation of
SQL results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping
where we map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs in a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are
they're feeded or well application and
they never reach the database other
methods of preventing SQL injection are
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use
oauth or some other service for a single
sign-on mechanism does you rely on a
third party
to maintain the security of
authentication and what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third
parties such as Facebook or Google
because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of Security
Experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is Top Notch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the Sure Shot method of
mitigating or minimizing the threat in
the first place so at this point in time
you have realized that the application
has some vulnerabilities for SQL
injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firewall to identify malicious queries
and stop them at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application and thus the vulnerabilities
on the application don't get executed
buy better software
and I'll keep on updating the software
so it's not necessary that once you have
a software you install it it's going to
be safe for Life new vulnerabilities are
discovered every day every hour and it
may so happen what is secure today
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after right so you need to keep
on upgrading the software if there are
no upgrades available and the
vulnerability still exists you might
want to migrate to a better software and
does ensure that you don't get hacked
right always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you're getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are creating uh are
not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have if you are
interested in pursuing a career in cyber
security and acquiring the necessary
skills then a postgraduate program in
cyber security in collaboration with the
MIT University is surely the right
option for you so hurry up and find the
course link mentioned in the description
box below for more details did you know
that in August this year Google openly
admitted that some of its Gmail accounts
for hackband Iranian group fortunately
the event was isolated and was taken
care of but rarely our security breaches
this easy to stop with more and more
data moving to the cloud the prospects
of hacks like these have grown in the
past decade exponentially
it's consequently organizations have now
discovered the need to secure the
digital infrastructure against various
attack vectors fueling the need for
ethical hackers in the IT industry let's
first clear the air on an ethical
Hacker's role the term hacking has
inherently negative connotations however
this will only be applicable until the
duty of an ethical hacker is properly
understood ethical hackers are the good
people in the hacking field wearing the
white hat so what exactly is the
responsibility of an ethical hacker
instead of utilizing the extensive
computer expertise for criminal purposes
ethical hackers find gaps in data and
computer security for businesses and
organizations worldwide to defend
themselves against hackers with less
than noble intentions ethical hacking is
a subcategory of cyber security that
involves lawfully breaking a system
security mechanisms in order to discover
possible threats and data leaks on the
network ethical hackers can work for
cooperation as independent Freelancers
in-house security staff for its website
or its applications or as simulated
offensive cyber Security Professionals
as well
all of these careers need knowledge of
current attack methodologies and tools
albeit the in-house expert may need to
be knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like Kali Linux and
parrot security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stress-free the better burst
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking the next would be to master the
mother of all programming languages
which is the C programming language
since Linux in a lot of back-end code
are written in C having a strong hand
over this programming language is very
important it's always helpful to learn a
couple more relevant languages like
python or JavaScript which will help you
dissect giant pieces of server code like
button
remaining Anonymous is vital in the
hacking sphere since giving a malicious
actor news of your existence on a Target
Network can cause him then to flee or
attack your device instead the usage of
Mac address randomizers and proxy chains
is highly beneficial and recommended
when monitoring networks for criminal
activity and speaking of proxies ethical
hackers must understand networking
fundamentals and exactly how they are
established learning about various
networks and protocols might help you
exploit flaws an ethical hacker with an
extensive understanding of networking
tools such as Wireshark nmap and others
can overcome field incidents relatively
unscale the fifth skill in our list is
traversing the dark web using the famous
store browser most of the internet is
hidden behind the torn networks and
getting a closer look at the people who
often are at the Forefront of the
hacking industry in the dark web
directly can help you familiarize
yourself with a certain domain Secrets
while keeping you updated with the
latest happenings in the cyber crime
World A major advantage that can tip the
skills in the favor of an ethical hacker
is the knowledge of cryptography for
encryption encryption is used in various
elements of information security
including authentication data Integrity
anonymity and others passwords and other
sensitive information are always
encrypted on our Network hacker must
understand how to recognize and break
these encryption standards exploring
vulnerabilities make you a better
ethical hacker simply keeps you aware of
the security measures that are kept in
place as industry standards while
handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security breach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to exploit the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
conversations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord ready Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum Natalie understands some B6
skills ethical hackers need to excel in
this domain let us look at the roadmap
one can follow to get started many
ethical hackers begin their careers by
studying computer science you can also
acquire an A plus certification from com
Tia by appearing for and passing to
additional tests these tests assess an
individual's understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain on
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCNA
certification guarantees the same skills
and stripes for foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support you'll be responsible
for monitoring and upgrading installing
security software and testing for
vulnerabilities you will obtain
expertise in network security and your
goal should be offered as a position as
a network engineer as a network engineer
you will build and plan networks rather
than simply maintain them your focus
should now be on the security part of
your journey to becoming an ethical
hacker this is the time to focus on
earning a security certifications such
as Security Plus or cisp the U.S
Department of Defense has approved the
Security Plus acquisition which covers
testing on critical areas such as Access
Control identity authentication and
cryptography the cissp certification is
a worldwide recognized security
acquisition that validates the expertise
of risk management Cloud technology and
application development
The Next Step would be to start working
in the information security Division and
information security analyst study
systems and network security engages
with security breaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain Hands-On
experiences some of the most essential
tools of the trade getting the certified
ethical hacker or the CES certification
should be your top priority the training
will teach you all you must understand
to become a productive and ethical
hacker you will be engaged in a Hands-On
environment where you will be guided
through breaking into a network and
finding any security flaws after
obtaining this certification you can
begin marketing yourself as a
professional ethical actor we have
already covered some skills one needs to
learn when starting their Journey
however an ethical hacker has certain
rules and responsibilities that must be
carried out ridiculously the first of
which is threat modeling threat modeling
is optimizing network security by
identifying vulnerabilities and
determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system
a threat is a real or projected negative
incident jeopardizing the organization's
assets the role of an ethical hacker is
to give a thorough assessment of
potentially harmful assaults and their
potential consequences they can also
conduct information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company
security
these regular exercises assess
Securities Readiness identify it system
weaknesses and offer strategies for
reducing future attack threads they also
assess how successfully security related
policies are implemented resulting in a
report that includes discovered flaws
and appropriate Solutions ethical
writers must be able to collect data
detect vulnerabilities and coordinate
risks to create clear and unambiguous
professional reports these evaluations
are frequently used to justify
finalizing security asset expenditures
the market for trained ethical hackers
has never been this expensive according
to various surveys the job outlet for
ethical hackers and information security
analysts is supposed to grow by 33
within 2020 and 2030. companies like IBM
Google and Microsoft are always on the
lookout for trained cyber security
Personnel in this climate of data
breaches and secures the important
question is how to become a certified
ethical hacker in order to become a
certified ethical hacker you need to
pass the certified ethical hacker or the
ceh exam from EC Council which tests the
broad knowledge of subject matter that
is required for someone to Be an
Effective ethical hacker well since its
Inception in 2003 the certified ethical
hacker has been the absolute choice of
the industry globally it is recognized
worldwide and has been endorsed by
governmental agencies like the and say
the CH exam is also is accredited by NC
which adds credibility and value to the
credential members the Cs exam is
computerized proctored exam you'll have
four hours to complete 125 questions
there are some sources of information
that mentions that in order to pass you
need to score about 60 to 80 percent the
actual percentage of questions that you
must answer correctly varies from exempt
exam and depends on the difficulty of
the exams delivered when you take the
exam the harder the questions that are
asked the fewer questions you need to
get right to pass the exam if you get
easier questions then you'll need to get
more of the questions right to pass the
exam however keep in mind that when you
take the actual exam at the testing
center the passing grade may vary the CH
certification exam costs 500 plus an
additional eligibility fee of hundred
dollars the exam duration is for four
hours the questions are all multiple
choice the exam is only available in
English as of today candidates can take
the CES exam online using a remotely
proctored service from anywhere in the
world 24 7 as long as they have a
computer equipped with a webcam and a
microphone let's discuss the exam
outline the exam is broken into seven
domains networking and information
background covers about 32 percent
analysis assessment covers 12 percent
security covers 23 percent tools system
programs 29 procedures methodology nine
percent regulation policy two percent
and ethics three percent let's discuss
these domains a little more in detail
networking and information background
this first domain of the ch exam is
designed to test your knowledge of
everything that you need to know to
practice ethical hacking which isn't
specific to any information security
domain the objectives of this domain
include Network and communication
Technologies next is information
security threats and attack Vector such
as malwares OAS top 10 Etc the final
objective covers information security
Technologies such as mobile technologies
telecommunication Technologies backups
archiving
Etc analysis assessment this domain of
the certified ethical hacker exam is
designed to test your knowledge of what
goes into performing a penetration test
or ethical hacking the objectives of
this domain are information security
assessment and Analysis and information
security assessment process combination
of ethics and regulation policy domains
covers five percent of the total exam
weightage the objectives of these
domains are ethics of information
security which covers what is considered
ethical and unethical from the
perspective of the ceh certification not
only you will be expected to behave
ethically you will be expected to adhere
to a code of ethics next objective is
information security policies laws acts
which covers some of the major
information security regulations and the
evaluation of organizational security
policies this is an important procedures
methodology this is an important domain
and carries a weightage of nine percent
there are two objectives the first
objective covers information security
procedures which is the step-by-step
methods that is used to identify prevent
and enforce security controls against
unwanted Behavior the next objective is
information security assessment
methodology which covers security
assessments to determine security gaps
that may pose a risk to the organization
tools systems programs this domain
carries the maximum weightage of 29 and
so you should expect the maximum number
of questions from here this domain is
heavily focused on knowledge of the
specific systems programs and tools used
in ethical hacking there are three
objectives first objective covers
information security systems such as
firewalls intrusion detection and
prevention systems Siem Solutions
Etc next objective covers information
security programs that are used to
secure a host system against malicious
attackers these programs include
antivirus anti-spyware anti-riskware ad
blockers anti-root kit Etc the final
objective covers information security
tools used for farming put Printing and
reconnaissance performing enumeration
conducting Network scanning performing
web application hacking Etc this
security domain is the second largest
domain on the exam with 23 percent
weightage this domain is divided into
three objectives the first objective
covers information security controls
such as administrative controls
technical controls and physical controls
the second objective information
security attack detection covers various
methods to detect attacks against an
organization's information security the
final objective information security
attack prevention covers proactive
methods that organizations can use to
protect themselves from malicious
attackers so are you ready to embark on
a journey into the world of cyber
security the digital age has assured in
unprecedented opportunities but it has
also brought forth new challenge and
threats and cyber attacks become more
sophisticated the demand for skilled
cyber Security Professionals is higher
than ever
with the symbol on cyber security
Masters program you can become a
guardian of the digital front view a
comprehensive curriculum hands-on
experience and expert instructors will
Empower you with the Knowledge and
Skills to thwart cyber security and
secure a rewarding career in this ever
evolving field
this course will train you on the
advanced step-by-step methodologies that
hackers actually use such as writing
virus codes and reverse engineering so
you can better protect corporate
infrastructure from data breaches not
only that but the ceh exam voucher is
also included in this course the only
requirement to enroll in this course is
Learners need to possess an
undergraduate degree or high school
diploma and one plus years of experience
is always preferred so hurry up and find
the course link mentioned in the
description box and pin comment join us
today and embark on a journey to
safeguard the digital world
and that's our app congratulations on
completing the ethical hacking crash
course you are now armed with insights
and skills to navigate the complex world
of cyber security responsibly and
ethically
if you like this session then like share
and subscribe if you have any questions
then you can drop them down in the
comment section below thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you